sorry about that representative sorry
our singer is from Milford not Merrimack
foreign
the chair recognizes the member from
Auburn representative Osborne who moved
the house adjourned from the session of
March 9 2023 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
and of course nay the eyes have it the
house will attend away Prayer by house
chaplain Reverend Bob Stewart pastor of
Saint Paul's United Methodist Church in
Manchester
be thou our vision o God
be our eyes
be our hearts
be the grace that flows through our
lives
only with and Through Your Eyes
can we see clearly
let us see each other clearly
and with that Clarity we see each other
with the respect we all expect and
deserve
be thou
our vision oh God
let us hear each other clearly
and with that listening ear
may we hear each other fully
before we engage in a response
be thou are hearing o God
oh God I ask that you give some of your
wisdom
to each member of this House of
Representatives
so they can make wise and meaningful
decisions today with each house bill
presented this day
be thou our wisdom o God
I lift each leader of this New Hampshire
State House
this morning and ask that you guide them
in their leadership
help each leader to sense your guiding
hand
in all they do this day
be thou our leadership
oh God
we pray all this to your glory o God
that through your grace we will receive
the gifts of your vision
your listening ear
your wisdom and your guiding hand of
leadership
we need to do the business presented
before us today
in gratitude we praise and glorify You O
Lord
amen
but you are recognize the member from
Merrimack representative Wendy Thomas
Liberty and
tomorrow
the chair recognizes Kevin Freeman of
Milford who will now sing our national
anthem
foreign
[Music]
what so proudly we here
at the twilight's last gleaming
who's brought stripes and bright stars
through the Peril of foreign
[Music]
that our flag was still there
oh say does that Star-Spangled then I
[Music]
[Applause]
the house will attend to request for
leaves of absence
Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives baroody Connor Sherry
gold hatch meniere muns teles the day
important business Representatives Hicks
lewicki Lloyd Finney Prout Schamberg
Tatro trottier the day illness in the
family Representatives Abbott and
Belcher
these leaves of action shall be Grant
unless otherwise ordered by the house
house will attend the introduction of
guests Mr Speaker please welcome in
order
please welcome Ken tassey Jr guest of
Representative Cole they're with us in
the gallery today
[Applause]
will now attend to the consent calendar
Mr Speaker there are no bills removed
from the consent calendar today
[Applause]
are there any other bills removed from
consent calendar with Senator Ogden
moves at the consent calendar with
irrelevant amendments is printed in
today's record be adopted are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye those proposed a the eyes having a
consent calendar is adopted the house
the committee on children and family law
to which was referred House Bill 497 FN
relative to the confidentiality of
Records within a Division of Youth and
families this comes to us without
recommendation
representative Panic moves
ought to pass
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
honorable colleagues I rise in
opposition to HB 497.
this bill represents a fundamental
misunderstanding of how dcyf case
records are accessed by parents wishing
a copy of their completed dcyf case File
currently state law requires dcyf to
release records to parents within a
certain time frame upon request
the commissioner of dcyf is allowed to
retain records if releasing them would
cause harm to a child this is done only
when there is a concurrent criminal
investigation about those exact same
allegations in those circumstances
releasing these those records would
interfere with the law enforcement
investigation
this bill seeks to take that decision
out of the hands of the police and the
dcyf commissioner and instead require
dcyf to petition family court and have a
family court judge decide if releasing
those records would impact the police
investigation putting aside the fact
that criminal matters are not under the
purview of the family court system we
know that the family court receives 127
000 new cases each calendar year were
this bill to be enacted dcyf could no
longer simply send a letter to a parent
saying that those records are being
retained and why instead they would have
to file a petition and family court wait
for a hearing date and then explain the
situation to a family court judge we
know that getting a hearing date in
Family Court takes months
currently a parent can get that letter
from dcyf much more quickly and then if
they disagree with the decision appeal
the decision to either the dcyf
Ombudsman or the independent Office of
the child advocate current law allows
families to find out what the
disposition of their request is much
more quickly than this bill would allow
I understand the frustration that
families feel when records are delayed
dcyf clearly has a staffing problem
but one could argue that the family
court system Staffing problems are worse
logically this bill would further muddle
the process instead of streamlining it
current statute dictates that the
division of children youth and families
shall release case records to certain
individuals and parties
unless
the harm to the child from the release
of those records outweighs
so far so good I think we can all agree
that releasing such information
if it is harmful to the child is a bad
thing
the question is
who makes that decision
who decides whether the harm to the
child outweighs the need to disclose
such information
well according to statute it is the
commissioner of Health and Human
Services
or her designee
so for practical purposes that means
that dcyf makes the decision
as to whether or not the harm to the
child outweighs the need to disclose
and dcyf determines whether they made
four decisions this important
it only makes sense to have reasonable
these decisions dramatically impact
people's lives consider the example
of a family of a parent or parents
who've been accused of wrongdoing
the New Hampshire Constitution part
first Article 15 pertains to the rights
of the accused
and among other things it says that you
have a right to be presented with the
the current system
arguably violates that section of the
Constitution
but accused parents are not the only
ones affected by this divorced or
separated parents likewise may be
seeking information
and we do know of cases where there are
civil cases
where information has been withheld
under this statute so it is not just
criminal cases
this bill established reason establishes
reasonable checks and balances
if dcyf believes that they
that the harm to the child outweighs the
need to disclose the information
they can simply petition the court
to issue a stay until a final decision
is made
this bill
creates reasonable checks and balances
and I urge my colleagues to press the
green button
on the ought to pass motion thank you Mr
Speaker
Jennifer has requested roll calls that's
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
clears
members take your seats this is a roll
has everybody turned your voting
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 497. this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative long for
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know House Bill 497
would create a long awaiting period for
parents and Guardians to go through this
process and I know that records such as
pediatricians and therapists are not
dcyf's records and this bill would
create unintended consequences would I
now press the red button thank you Mr
Speaker gee I recognize representative
Mr Speaker if I know due process is a
critical part of both our civil and our
Criminal Justice System Mr Speaker if I
know that checks and balances on a
department is a good thing
and Mr Speaker lastly if I know that
protecting kids should be an important
portion would I now press green on the
auto pass motion thank you
question before us is the ought to pass
motion on House Bill 497 it's a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button for a poser press
a red button voting stations are open
the ball members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
178 voting yay 173 voting a committee
reporters adopted
as a member rise
to make the motion of reconsideration
the motion before us is reconsideration
of house bill 497. this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your poster press the
red button voting stations are open for
also of all members president an
opportunity to vote house will attend a
174 voting a 182 voting a the motion
fails
every single bill that we have on the
calendar today I think except one has a
debate
so the more you can stay in your seats
and I'm sure robly almost every single
one will be a division or a roll call
so the more you stay in your seats the
quicker we can get done
we lose about an hour a day
when we ask for a roll call or a
division and we have to wait for people
to come in
so if you will cooperate we'll get done
maybe about an hour earlier thank you
representative Muse moves Auto pass
on House Bill 76 the committee on
criminal justice and Public Safety to
which was referred House Bill 76 posing
a waiting period between the purchase
and delivery of a firearm comes to us
without recommendation
and vice representative moves ought to
pass chair recognize representative
Rhodes
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker House Bill 76
says anybody that goes in to purchase a
firearm has to wait three days in order
to do so
during committee we heard exactly what
you'd think we would hear we heard about
people that commit suicide or people
that are going to do or have intention
to create great harm
and that's all very sad and nobody wants
that to happen
so the bill says don't worry we got you
if you're a hunter and you took your
hunting course
it doesn't doesn't apply to you you
don't have to worry about that but it
doesn't say you know when you had to
have taken the course or if there's a
waiting period to take that course
it says if you're in law enforcement
don't worry it doesn't apply to you
it says if you are active duty military
doesn't say anything about if you're a
veteran just active duty
and my personal favorite
if a woman expresses fear to her local
law enforcement officer
so I brought this up in committee and I
said you know this doesn't work for me I
no I don't think that we're going to
tell a woman that she has to wait three
days to protect herself
and then I went back and I clarified and
I said I do recognize that it says here
that if a woman goes to her local law
enforcement and expresses fear that she
doesn't have to wait three days
but I also said it doesn't say how you
express that fear are you supposed to
just say hey I'm afraid you're supposed
to fill out a form exactly what are we
supposed to do
then there was a local newspaper that
did a really nice gotcha hook on a
headline that said representative
refuses to care
okay and it said
representative Rhodes throughout the
typical
Damsel in Distress card
let me explain to you what a damsel in
distress is
a damsel in distress says
a woman
that is waiting for a man to come save
her
I will not
go to my local law enforcement
and beg for permission
for my god-given right to defend myself
now or three days from now
and when you
house will be in order when you can
figure out how to get an abusive man or
a rapist to take a three-day cooling
down period which I think is highly
unlikely because we can't even get them
to have to stay in jail for three days
and see a judge
until that day I will continue to
protect myself thank you very much thank
I recognize representative Muse
a roll call has been requested it is has
been sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote and we're on our final
speaker
thank you Mr Speaker
um this is actually a simple bill that
would establish a three-day waiting
period between the time a firearm is
sold and between the time a new owner
can actually pick it up
uh the bill won't create a situation uh
we're a three-day waiting period turns
into a four or five or six day waiting
period uh because uh we're talking about
calendar days uh not business days
under both current state and federal law
no waiting period is required to
purchase a firearm by passing uh this
bill we'd be changing that at the New
Hampshire level and we'd also be doing a
couple of very important things
a waiting period would give Law
Enforcement Officers extra time to
perform an accurate background check to
make sure that we're keeping Firearms
out of the hands of a person who
actually shouldn't have one
but more importantly what it does is it
creates a cooling off period to reduce
the risk of a violent act or a suicide
attempt
so in New Hampshire
we have a small problem when it comes to
homicides by firearm but we have a very
large problem when it comes to suicides
by firearm according to the chief
medical examiner in 2020
91 percent of New Hampshire's firearms
deaths that's 118 out of 129 were
suicides
um one of the other things that we know
is that your chances of succeeding in a
suicide if you use a firearm you your
the odds are you're going to be about 91
successful so unlike other forums uh
other types of ways or other ways to
take your own life taking your life by
firearm is something that is more likely
than not to prove fatal
um we would be the first to tell you
that this is not going to end firearm
suicide or gun violence in the state of
New Hampshire but what it will do is
help reduce the risk of suicide and some
of these uh impulsive acts by people who
really could benefit from a cooling off
period And if like me if you've sat in
in public hearings and this didn't
happen on this particular bill but it
happened on one like it and you've heard
from mothers who
have had kids in that situation and had
a child actually go to a gun shop buy a
firearm and then commit suicide
you wonder what kind of a difference
would a three-day waiting period have
meant in the mind of a of a troubled
laughs
so in terms of the exceptions of that HB
76 adds
um that uh that the representative went
over in the majority report or in her
report
um
one of the things that I would like to
say is that many of those are the
product of actually having talked to and
listened to people on the other side of
the aisle who have another point of view
about these issues that's why those
exceptions are in there
and one of the things I think that's
very important to realize about this
bill is we're not putting people in a
situation where if they've been
threatened or if they're being protected
if they're being if they're under the
protection of a protective order where
they would not be able to get a firearm
that's why these exceptions are in there
um
another argument that we hear all the
time about these bills is that they're
unconstitutional
and then in a system that prizes
individual rights any attempt to balance
an individual right with Public Safety
or or any social concern flies in the
face of what the founding fathers
intended
and that might be a winning argument if
the founding fathers had actually
stopped at listing rights when they
wrote both our state and federal
Constitution
is not what they did
they also outlined a system to make and
enforce laws and they did this because
they wisely recognized that they needed
ways to balance and peacefully settle
conflicts between individuals who are
exercising their rights
at every level of government we have
laws that rightly and correctly place
limits on individual actions we have
freedom of speech but not the freedom to
libel we have freedom to practice our
religion but not to force others to
practice it we have the right to keep
and bear arms but not to use them to
harm or to threaten others
Central to both our state and federal
Constitution is the idea that in a civil
society individual rights cannot be
absolute
in other words to protect Public Safety
and avoid creating a society where
literally anything goes the rights of
individuals must be balanced against the
rights of others
first two articles of our own New
Hampshire Bill of Rights are very clear
about the natural rights that we have as
Citizens including the right to bear
arms
but strategically placed by our founding
fathers directly underneath them is
article 3.
article 3 could not be more clear when
it comes to our duty to balance the
rights of individuals with the rights of
others
it reads in part when men enter into a
state of society they surrender up some
of their natural rights to that Society
in order to ensure the protection of
others
so while there are many things we might
call HB 76
one thing that we cannot call it is an
affront to the Constitution
what this bill would do is take one
small step towards reducing the risk of
gun violence and suicide in New
Hampshire and bring us back into a
proper balance between respect for the
rights of individuals to own firearms
and our responsibility to ensure the
protection of others
so please vote with me vote green to
support the ought to Pat motion for HB
thank you as a member yield the
questions
sure remember yields
and thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
representative for taking my question
you mentioned the part one article 3 of
The Constitution and the word others
isn't it possible that the word others
means other natural rights rather than
other people as you are assuming
I don't believe that's the way it's been
interpreted
um
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 76 this is going to be a roll
uh
motion before us is ought to pass in
House Bill 76 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative Roy for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know
while discussing the founding fathers
that Paul Revere did not say The British
are coming in three days
and if I know
that a right delayed is a right denied
and finally Mr Speaker if I know a woman
should never have to ask a man for
permission to defend herself would I
press the red button and overturn the
ought to pass so another motion can be
made
see I recognize representative Newman
Mr chair
correct correction my apologies Mr Mr
Speaker
if I know that a brief waiting period
that this bill provides can prevent
suicide
by providing a cooling off period to a
troubled person who impulsively wants to
fire to
purchase a firearm to commit suicide
and if I know that 90 of suicide
survivors do not go on to die by Suicide
but because of the lethality of firearms
85 percent of people who use guns to
commit suicide will not get that second
chance
and finally that if I know that people
who need quick access to firearms for
self-defense are exempt from the waiting
period if they have a restraining order
or they express their reasonable fear
for their personal safety to a law
enforcement officer and you can express
it to any law enforcement officer
anytime you are exempt from the
three-day waiting period so don't worry
about Paul Revere
would I now pass this completely
constitutional gun Suicide Prevention
bill that is supported by 85 percent of
non-gun owners and 72 percent of gun
owners by pressing the green button and
I do have references for any percentages
yeah there's a parliamentary inquiry
the motion the motion before us is ought
to pass on House Bill 76 this is a roll
call vote you're in favor you'll press
the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
ball members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
168 voting yay 193 voting a the motion
for what reason does a member arrives
Mr Speaker I'd like to make a motion
State commotion I'd like to move in
expedient to legislate motion before us
is inexpedient to legislate are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
as opposed nay
the eyes have it
I'm sorry the vote was beyond the uh
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety to which those deferred House
Bill 89 act relative to posthumous
exonerations and annulments we consider
the same report the same with the
following Amendment a recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment Senator David Muse for the
committee
the amendment is zero four seven two H
printed in house record 15 pages 27-28
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
George bosnay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
House Bill 89 as we just amended it
recognizes that there are three branches
of the state government one the governor
the Judiciary
and this house oh I'm sorry the General
Court House and Senate
the governor we recognize can pardon he
has the sole power to pardon
and the court has the sole power of
annulling a conviction
with this bill as amended would do is to
recognize that the general court would
have the ability to posthumously
exonerate somebody
and what does that mean
that means that
over time
this the general court recognizes that I
manifest Injustice of the law or policy
has happened by a conviction
so also in the bill are two individuals
that our committee and I think you've
seen this bill and heard this bill many
times in the past if you've been in the
house for many years
that have definitely had a
bad rap
one being
goody coal Eunice Cole of Hampton now
back when she was put before the court
and convicted of
the state of New Hampshire didn't exist
it was the province of New Hampshire but
at the time when a it
also now known as Hampton was actually a
Township that was
put together by the Commonwealth of
Massachusetts and not by New Hampshire
because the the Mason Grant wasn't
enforced so
what happened when she was put before
the court was she was dragged into
Massachusetts
convicted by a court in Massachusetts
and
she was also imprisoned in prison down
there
we recognized that
there was a scare in Salem Massachusetts
about witches and and we realized that
you know what we were wrong
and through this bill we're going to say
we're sorry
a second individual
is Willow Dump house if if you don't
know the story I I don't want to take
all the Time in the World to talk about
it but he was persecuted by our attorney
general in the last century
for not giving up information that he
was should have been protected by our
Bill of Rights and by this bill we're
also exonerating his
record by the general court and I'd ask
you to vote for the bill as it has been
amended thank you Mr Speaker
and janvin has requested a division
foreign
pass as amended on House Bill 89. this
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed or press
the red button voting stations are open
all men was president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
375 voting a 45 voting a committee
majority of committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety to which those
referred House Bill 328 FN enact
legalizing certain Controlled Substances
for persons 21 years of age or older
consider the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpeding to legislation of Terry
Roy for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee have
considered the same to be an unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation to build a lot of pass
representative John R wheeler for the
minority of the committee
thank you Mr Speaker
so we've had a lot of these quote
free drugs
are your fear
God bless you
file a bill and address it get rid of
caffeine get rid of sugar get rid of
nicotine get rid of alcohol those are
your gateway drugs this is not a gateway
drug discussion this bill is specific to
lysergic acid diethylamide LSD
which is a synthetic compound one of the
few popular synthetic psychedelics
psilocybin which is the active in
psychedelic mushrooms
there's no psilocybin in psychedelic
mushroom spores and so those can be
transported possessed legally in the
United States you can go online and you
can buy yourself a mushroom growing kit
from any reputable dealer you can take
your psilocybin spores and you can grow
mushrooms at at home or buy them on the
black market
masculine is a little bit of an outlier
on this one mescaline is the active and
peyote Cactus grows in the desert
Southwest
okay so why not include it
these compounds are not addictive
these compounds are not habit forming
these compounds have the unique
characteristic
that if you use them on a regular basis
the effect is diminished
and if you're chasing the high
and you take more
you don't get the high
a tolerance is quickly established and
the only way to get the high back
is to wait
to let your body go back to equilibrium
but wait so it's self-controlling but
wait there's more
unlike dangerous drugs
drugs that we should not legalize like
amphetamines like barbiturates like
narcotics
these compounds are non-toxic
in fact LSD has no ld50
what's an ld50 you ask ld50 is the
amount of substance that you give to a
general population that kills half of
them
alcohol has an ld50 heroin has an ld50
cocaine has an ld50
LSD has no ld50 the only way to kill
somebody with LSD would be to
crystallize enough of it and drop it on
it's a fact
I sympathize
with Junkies
I sympathize with people that sympathize
and I want to get them the help they
need
psychedelics have been shown and proven
to be effective in the treatment of
okay
the founder of Alcoholics Anonymous in
the 1950s used LSD to great effect to
if you wanna If You Wanna Stop drug
addiction in this country then you need
to join me in voting red to overturn the
itl so that another motion can be made
this bill is common sense these
compounds were swept up into the world
of illegality back in the 1960s
as a knee-jerk reaction
we all know the CIA
under MK Ultra
tried using psychedelics as mind control
drugs didn't work they tried to use it
as truth serum drugs it didn't work do
you know what these compounds produce
I'll tell you what they produce they
produce pea snacks
they produce peaceness and you know what
the government was not interested in in
the early mid and late 1960s was
peacenix
and that's why these compounds were
swept up into the to the drug laws was
to prevent making young people into
peace next because they wanted people to
go into southeast Asia and kill other
people
that's why I filed this bill this is
good Common Sense legislation I don't
want these compounds to be legal
representative Virgo okay God bless you
it won't be these compounds will not be
legal
they won't be illegal in New Hampshire
but federally they will still be illegal
and controlled compounds if the feds
really want to go and police this then
let them police it
okay when is the last time we had a big
psychedelics bust in New Hampshire I I
asked the narcotics Chief from the state
police that that question when he came
to testify against this bill
he had an interesting answer
he said I I don't know I'm not aware of
one
but
oh there's a butt
but my kids are in high school
and they say mushrooms are everywhere
all the kids that want them have them
and they're doing them
so
so the prohibition is completely
ineffective and because we we make it a
boogie man kids are interested in it
right if you wanna if you want to help
people that have drug problems work with
me to get these compounds back to
availability so that we can treat people
I ask you I beg you press the red button
let's overturn the itl so another motion
could be made and so we can actually
help people thank you Mr Speaker
representative William Walsh has
requested a wall call it is sufficiently
seconded we're down to our last speaker
thank you Mr Speaker
I agree with much of what my colleague
just said
with regard to to the part about um you
need to drop it on someone's head uh in
a mass amount to kill them there's
another way to make it lethal and that's
to give it to a 17 year old and put him
behind the wheel of a five thousand
pound car
and he thinks that someone's a dragon
and runs them over
it's a psychedelic it Alters your
perception of reality
maybe it's helpful matter of fact it
probably is helpful in certain
controlled circumstances
but to just turn it loose on the public
where anyone can have access to it now
the bill says 21 and over we know good
and well that somehow miners find a way
to get things that are only for 21 and
over otherwise we wouldn't have alcohol
problems with teenagers
so to turn this loose on the public with
no control
is very dangerous
we cannot tell if someone right now is
inebriated on marijuana when they're
driving how in Earth will we tell if
someone has taken LSD there's no test
for that
furthermore LSD is
a substance that stays in your system
for a while it's stored in your fat
cells and it can be reactivated at any
time there's scientific proof of people
having a new experience days or weeks
after they've taken the drug so they
don't know when it's going to hit they
could take it feel better and then
a day or two later while they're
operating a machine it comes back
so there's a this is a dangerous
substance to be given to someone without
experience with it under no control
and as I said if it has medical benefits
it should come back as a medical bill
but to just cut it loose on the public
is a dangerous proposition
and I would ask you to oh one final
thing if you want marijuana legal in the
state
it's best not to do this at the same
time
the federal government has been turning
a blind eye to States legalizing
marijuana
how far do you want to push that before
they start cracking down and we start
legalizing everything then they're going
to turn and they're going to say wait a
minute and put the brakes on it all and
you'll jeopardize that as well
so it's up to you to choose but I would
ask for you to support the committee's
position of inexpediate the legislate
thank you
the motion before us is the majority
committee report event expedient to
legislator and House Bill 328 this is
going to be a roll call vote members
player
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of nxp to legislative
House Bill 328 it's a roll call vote
chair recognized representative verville
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know by the
Sea agreeing that I see the future does
not look good for me
but also Mr Speaker if I know
that LSD flashbacks are a myth
and that LSD does not reside in your fat
cells for indeterminate amount of times
and the metabolism of LSD is about 6 to
12 hours in the human body
if I also know that we don't have cars
careening off the roads Left Right
willy-nilly because people are under the
influence of psychedelics today
and making it legal in New Hampshire is
not going to make that happen and Mr
Speaker if I also know this is only for
consenting adults over the age of 21
would I now not press what I now press
the red button
press the red button to overturn the itl
so that another more reasonable motion
Geo recognizes representative
by nowhere
speakers if I know that everybody
already has their mind made up I would
the motion before us is the majority
commit a report of inexpediate
legislature in House Bill 328 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
will press the red button voting
foreign
members president had an opportunity to
290 voting yay 76-49a committee report
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety to which
chosen Courthouse Bill 360 FN enact a
legalizing cannabis for person 21 years
of age or older having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution result that is inexpedient to
legislate Senator Terry Roy for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation that the pill ought to
pass Senator Jody knew well for the
minority of the committee the chair
thank you Mr Speaker
back again for my second favorite topic
so several years ago
I was lucky enough to be a member of
this body and we voted to decriminalize
three-quarters of an ounce of marijuana
and guess what happened
it passed passed the governor vetoed it
sad day and then it came back to the
House and Senate and we overrode The
veto good day
you know what's really interesting is
since that happened
the sky
did not fall
I know shocking right Sky did not fall
six years well almost seven now in this
this August body
and one thing I've learned
we like simple bills
We Like Short bills when bills get
complicated when they get long and they
get confusing people vote against them
this is the shortest easiest way to
affect the change that the majority of
our constituents want and that is the
legalization of cannabis
right
I also know from my years in this body
that taxation is theft
and this bill does not have
the carrot
of Revenue
just because we allow people to do
something
doesn't mean that the state has to get
a cut of the action
why don't we
finally step up to the plate
fully decriminalize marijuana in New
Hampshire for consenting adults
why don't we keep the state out of the
right
does anybody run numbers in New
Hampshire anymore
now you know why because we let the
state run numbers that's what the
lottery is the the lotteries is a number
scam
for those of you that don't like the
drug industry the drug business
fair enough I'm not really a big fan
either believe it or not
then why would you want to put the
government in charge of the racket
cut the government out of the racket so
let's do what the vast majority in New
Hampshire citizens want us to do and
that is finally decriminalize marijuana
and so I ask you to press the red button
overturn the itl so that another more
common sense motion can be made thank
thank you Mr chair
oh Mr
third time's a charm now I'm the last
one everybody's good
uh
we have multiple bills attempting to
legalize cannabis
we've been at this for years and still
struggling to get it done the people of
New Hampshire
favor legalization so far we have failed
them
many of my colleagues are resting their
hopes on the passage of the bipartisan
cannabis legalization Bill HB 639 and
I'm in support of that one as well
so why am I asking you to support this
one well let's get into it
cannabis should have never been
criminalized in the first place as a
matter of fact criminalization began
with attacks
the marijuana Tax Act of 1937. here we
are
this was in fact the very beginning of
the war on drugs or should I say the war
on people is no matter who the stated
enemy it's time for us to recognize that
this war has been an abject failure
many of our neighbors have been lost to
this war my children and I are
collateral damage in this war their
father died of a heroin overdose when he
had the threat of a 15-year mandatory
minimum hanging over his head
we feel that loss every day
many in New Hampshire feel that loss as
well
our approach to this issue needs to
change
while I wholeheartedly believe that this
change needs to be implemented
rationally strategically and carefully
cannabis simply is not heroin it's not
fentanyl cannabis simply does not carry
the same risk for harm
or overdose as these other substances
and yet great harm is done when members
of our community are stopped searched
and detained left with criminal records
or wait criminal records simply for
cultivating and consuming a plant
cannabis can be grown safely and
discreetly in our backyard gardens and
consumed in the comfort of our own homes
this bill provides for that
a few years ago I also lost my brother
his drug of choice was alcohol
and it and it ultimately took his life
alcohol poisoned his body yet alcohol is
legal
because we accept that some people will
misuse certain substances but we allow
individuals to moderate themselves
I would argue
that the Cannabis that cannabis carries
a much lower risk than alcohol a
substance which again is legal
but as we stand here and we vet and
debate these other cannabis bills the
harm of criminalization continues
that said I will vote in favor of any
effort to legalize cannabis with a
strong preference for those which do not
impose a barrier between myself and my
garden or place a tax on something I can
easily grow in it and with that I ask
you to pass press the red button thank
you
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
I might support this bill
if it were not federally illegal it is
currently illegal we can make it legal
here but it's not legal because the
federal government still says it's
illegal so if we are going to do
anything further than we've already done
with cannabis it has to be done very
carefully very thoughtfully and in a way
that will not
draw attention to the fact that we are
flouting federal law
now
if it were not federally legal I might
support it but it is
furthermore what we also don't do in
this house is pass bills that are going
nowhere
and we know this bill's going nowhere
why would we bother to pass it and send
it on when we know its future already
we have several other bills we're
working on that have a brighter future
so vote with me to support the committee
representative Willie Walsh has
requested a roll call us that's
requested division vote this will be a
division vote
here
the motion before us the majority
committed report of any speeding to
legislative in house bill 360. house
will be in order
this is a division vote chair recognizes
representative Alexandria Murray for a
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that cannabis is legalized in every
state surrounding New Hampshire and if I
know that our constituents have been
begging us to legalize it here and if I
know that there are other bills that
will have unpredictable outcomes in the
other body Mr Speaker would I now want
to double our chances at cannabis
legalization by pressing the red button
jail recognizes representative mannion
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that while some
members of the committee are opposed to
legislation due to health and traffic
safety reasons a majority of the
committee members agree
with the marijuana legalization in
principle but felt that this bill was
not the best legislation to accomplish
that
and if I know that other legislation
before other committees is the best
vehicle to accomplish this
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that
according to Mr Mckay school council at
South Park Elementary that drugs are bad
when I now press the green button
thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us to the majority
committed report of inexped into
legislative and house bill 360. this is
a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press a green button of your
opposed you'll press the red button
well members president had an
opportunity to vote also tend to state
for what reason does the member rise I
Rise to make a motion Mr Speaker stage
of motion I move Ito on House Bill 360.
I mean I'm sorry
it's one of those four
representative Roy warned me about I
move OTP on House Bill 360 please
I believe I heard you motion a lot of
the motion before us is ought to pass in
House Bill 360. are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
hey
the eyes have it and the motion of ought
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety to which was
referred House Bill 444fn enact
prohibiting possession of a firearm at a
polling place having considered the same
report the same with the Fallen
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislation of David mannion for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation that the bill Otto pass
representative Jody Newell for the
thank you very much I believe you'll get
two members from Durham today so this is
our lucky day so the house the house
will be in order the member has a right
to be heard
okay
well I'm the I'm the prime sponsor
actually the only sponsor of HP 444 but
it has like wide support aside from
myself happily I'm not the first
legislature to try to address the issue
of firearms at the polling place but
hopefully we pass this bill in the law I
can be the last so I've been attending
elections for over 60 years now even
before I turned 18 my parents they were
the type of citizens who insisted on
voting in every election they were the
type of parents who liked to bring their
kids to the polling place with them so
I've seen a lot of things of public
places as a voter as a kid taking a lot
my parents as a campaign worker and I've
really never seen a violent crime being
committed at the polling place
um I've never seen seen lots of things
go wrong I've never seen anything happen
the election officials couldn't handle
on their own without uh Without fire and
they've already solved it without the uh
without any shots being fired obviously
so your name cognitive the
possibility of problems and I'm
certainly glad that pulling places
always have a robust police presence
aside from
well aside from deterring crime they're
also part of the elections process
because they're the ones who are
responsible for uh delivering it's the
law enforcement Community delivers
election materials to the Secretary of
State's office
and also there's
we we have good turnout here at
elections so there's always a need for
uh directing traffic so
I will
you know I would admit it's pretty rare
to see anyone open carrying at the
polling place but I think uh I think
I think it's a good thing you don't
often see people open carrying at the
polling places I find that uh
well some people and I'm one of them and
you can call us names call us
haplophobes but I find that to be
intimidating rather than reassuring
and in any case it's uh it's unnecessary
because there's a robust police presence
and this bill makes things as simple as
possible for gun owners and non-gun
owners alike
by simply banning guns and other deadly
weapons between 100 feet of the polling
place using the commonly understood
meaning of the term polling place it's
um you know it's pretty easy to figure
out where the polling place was or quite
clearly marked so you're I don't think
there's much you'd have to be pretty
oblivious to wander into polling place
without knowing you're wandering into a
polling place with your gun or without
your gun so
um there are there's a specific carve
out for weapons secured to the vehicles
even those parked within 100 feet of the
printing place
there's also a car valve for law
enforcement officers whether they're on
duty or whether they're simply
exercising the right to vote
and we also fairly Progressive absentee
voting laws so if you really really
can't stand to be without your gun for
the few minutes it takes to cast a
ballot you can vote absentee so
um I urge you to uh
I urge you to vote ought to pass on HB
444 thanks
today in opposition of the itl motion
for HB 444
in case you are one of the very few
people who didn't know New Hampshire is
an open carry state meaning gun owners
can openly carry a loaded firearm
without any license or permit
in fact since 2017 the state has allowed
any gun owner to carry a concealed
weapon without a license
armed intimidation is voter suppression
plain and simple
the this is uh this undemocratic form of
harassment is unlawful and is an affront
to our safety as well as the Integrity
of America's free and fair elections
some gun owners might be worried about
the possibility of encountering
criminals
abusers or other threats snow plow
drivers at the polling place and they
should be able to take solace on the
fact that there will always be law
enforcement officers on duty there
HB 444 asked people not to carry their
guns within a hundred feet of a polling
place
the same distance as those wishing to be
out electioneering on voting days
including during a nor'easter
HP 444 even has a specific carve out for
unloaded weapons secured in Motor
Vehicles including those parked within
100 feet of a polling place
for those of you who do not believe that
guns and polling places are intimidating
there are others who strongly disagree
couple of examples one town clerk said I
am not a fan of guns and polling places
especially if they are in schools as a
town employee and a mother who is a
student in the building it makes me very
uncomfortable I worry for the safety and
well-being of our poll volunteers
residents colleagues and students in the
building
one election volunteer reported that
guns at polling places makes them feel
very unsafe they say people should trust
election officials and the officers
providing election security to do their
jobs
it would make this volunteer even more
intimidated to have the person carrying
standing in the observer's area
one voter reported that it makes them
extremely uneasy to see guns at the
polls and that it's completely
unnecessary to carry a gun in a polling
place they emphasized that especially in
a place where people are gathering it
increases the concern for someone being
hurt either intentionally or
accidentally
during our executive session one of our
committee members also spoke about how
guns at polling places left her feeling
intimidated and unsafe when she voted
Court Justice Clarence Thomas agreed the
right to vote freely and without
intimidation supersedes the right to
carry
New Hampshire legislators should do the
right thing and veto the itl on HB 444
in order to protect New Hampshire voters
so another motion can be made and Mr
Speaker I request a division vote this
remember yielded questions
no member does not yield
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker we have been carrying
firearms at polling places so for I
don't know a couple hundred years now
in if it's intimidating voters
I don't know how because we don't seem
to win all the elections
so I'm not really sure how they're
intimidated
because they're certainly showing up
we haven't had an issue we have never
had an issue at a polls we just had a
election in some towns with a blizzard
and police weren't able to make it the
people made it they voted
no issues again
if anyone in New Hampshire sees some
with a firearm in his surprise shocked
or intimidated I don't know where
they've been because again we've been
having guns for a couple hundred years
now it's not a shock it's in the New
Hampshire Constitution the United States
Constitution and in those constitutions
it does not say you have to sacrifice
one right in order to exercise another
please support the committee in voting
with the itl thank you
representative Senator toaster was
requested a roll call
is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpinning to
legislate and House Bill 444
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative Moose
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that the presence
of firearms at polling places can serve
to intimidate voters and election
workers and if I know that a recent
Brennan Center survey found that more
than 50 percent of the election workers
surveyed expressed fear for their
personal safety
and if I know this country also has a
long and a very sad history of guns
being used by one group of people to
keep other groups of people from boating
and finally Mr Speaker if I also know
that as recently as June of last year
the U.S Supreme Court made it clear that
states are free to restrict the
possession of guns at polling places
under the Second Amendment
then when I press the red button so
another motion can be made thank you
Geo recognized representative Rhodes for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that intimidation
with the firearm is illegal
no matter where you are in the state of
New Hampshire
and if I know that crime and violence
is illegal at a polling place
and if I know that I should not have to
give up one right to exercise another
would I now press the green button and
support the committee recommendation
thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is a majority
committed report of inexpeding to
legislature and House Bill 444 it's a
roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you're opposed or press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
while members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
202 voting yay 167 voting a committee
before we get to the next bill we've had
numerous complaints about members not
being able to hear while they're sitting
in their seats
I ask again if you need to have a
conversation please take it into the
ante room so the members that are in
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety to which is referred House Bill
596 FM prohibiting the use of racial
profiling in law enforcement activities
and incendancy comes to us without
recommendation
cinemuse offers ought to pass
with Amendment
the amendment is zero five nine six H
printed in-house record 15 page 33. you
ready for the question on the amendment
all those in favor say aye
those opposed May
[Applause]
only members that were in the chamber on
The Voice vote can vote
if you weren't in the chamber on The
the motion before us is on the amendment
we had a Voice vote a division was
requested this will be a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed will
press the red button voting stations are
foreign
was President an opportunity to vote
178 voting yay 186 voting a the
the question now is on ought to pass on
House Bill 596.
chair recognize the representative
this bill explicitly prohibits New
e yes
law enforcement Personnel from targeting
individuals for suspicious of a crime
based on the individual's race
ethnicity color National Origins
nationality language sex gender identity
and sexual orientation political
affiliations
religion
social economic status
or disability
it further clarifies that these
characteristics shall not be a factor in
determining the existence of probable
cause
to arrest or to be placed an individual
into custody
the bill provides clear guard rails to
prevent demographic characteristics
that have nothing to do with criminal
activity from being used as a factor to
constitute reasonable suspicions that an
offense has been committed in order to
detain
an individual or to stop a motor vehicle
but to be clear this is nothing in the
bill that prevents a law enforcement
officer from using a physical
description to apprehend a specific
suspect linked to and identify criminal
in New Hampshire people of all Races
ethnicity religions and colors relying
on the police to protect us from harm
and promote fairness and Justice in our
communities
but racial profiling has led some of our
neighbors who may not look or speak like
the majority of our residents to live in
fear
simply because they look different come
from a different place or practice a
different religion
while the governor 2021 law enforcement
accountability community and
transparency liat commission made a
series of legislative recommendations on
Gathering racial profiling data
some have yet been enacted
meanwhile the act of racial profiling
itself has never been explicitly
prohibited by New Hampshire law it is
time to do so as over 30 other states
our state has the unique distinction of
having passed a motorcycle profiling law
but not a racial profiling law
there is a problem here in New Hampshire
and we can address that issue because I
believe that everyone in here in this
room today realize what's happening in
New Hampshire not talking about across
the state talking about right here
I know you have friends you might even
have family members that experience the
same situations
and all we're asking is that we as a
body stand and say
it's not okay here in the state of New
Hampshire
before there was ever a name for racial
profiling
it has been ingrained in our country law
enforcement practices
from a public safety perspective racial
profiling
results in a loss of trust and
confidence in our law enforcement
it involves the unwarranted screening of
certain groups of people
assumed by law enforcement agents to be
predisposed to criminal activity whereas
we all know that is not true as well
so thank you Mr Speaker
I recognize your representative De
Lorenzo
I stand in support of HB 596 as amended
as a black woman I believe that I was
racially profiled by law enforcement in
a New Hampshire town
this was a couple of years ago it's one
Saturday morning I was driving to the
Market Basket supermarket in surrattam
on my way
to the market I drove past the stratum
police station
and a few seconds later I glanced in my
rear view mirror and I noticed a town of
Stratton police cruiser with flashing
blue lights behind my car
well
as I know it's the law to pull aside
pull to the side when you see flashing
blue lights I pulled over and start my
car and
looked into my rear view mirror and I
realized that I was the one that was
being stopped
so I was a little bit frightened and I
just so I just sat in my car I tried to
remember to do what my parents and aunts
and uncles told me to do when you're
approached by the police and that is to
um
get your license and registration out
be polite don't talk back be respectable
to the officer
so
the officer approached me I handed her
my license in registration I didn't
bother to ask her why I was being
stopped I think I was kind of in shock
and so
as I sat there waiting for the report to
come through I was thinking to myself
you know why is this happening to me
there's nothing wrong with my car my car
is in perfect condition
um it's daytime so it wasn't like a
headlight out or anything and
um all of my my registration was valid
my driver's license was valid my
insurance was valid and so I just sat
there thinking about what my elders told
tried to follow that
well a few minutes later the officer
returned to my car and told me that I
she told me that she was looking for a
red
Chrysler PT Cruiser vehicle
my vehicle was a red Toyota Prius
there's no way you could mistake a Prius
as I am relating to this you can tell
but it still bothers me I still wonder
you know why did that happen why
would someone's thought me I'm a wife
I'm a mother I'm a grandmother
you know
um you know it's just going to the store
to get bread and milk on a Sunday
morning
thank you thank you Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker we heard testimony in the
committee in an area concern that was
raised was Title 18 U.S code section 242
already making it a crime
for a person acting under color of law
to willfully deprive a person of a right
or privilege protected by the
is there a possibility that political
influence could lead to investigation
subsequent prosecution
with demographic makeup different areas
within the state affect the standards
it's used to determine racial profiling
this legislation leads to allegations of
racial profile against officers based on
statistics only
will all offices be treated equally
regardless of race
the committee
was not provided any answers
the sponsor of this bill remarked
they want to make a statement that
racial profiling is not allowed in this
state
laws are not appropriate methods to make
statements
our laws must prohibit specific conduct
in a clear and articable manner so that
citizens can understand what
specifically is prohibited and what
consequences are for violating the law
New Hampshire police standards and
training Council provides extensive
training on the topic of racial
profiling and Civil Right issues the
state county and local law enforcement
agencies currently have the authority to
enact policies related to racial
profiling they also have the ability to
deal with any performance issues related
to sustained violations of these
policies
in closing racial profiling is already
illegal under federal law as it has been
this bill looks to provide a further
divide within the criminal justice
system
and I would ask that you please vote no
on the auto pass so that another more
appropriate motion could be brought
forward thank you Mr Speaker
we're down to the last speaker there has
been a roll call request
is sufficiently seconded so members take
your seats the chair recognizes
thank you Mr Speaker I rise in support
of this bill not as a black man as you
can see because that is visible but I
stand up here in support of this bill
because it's in our heart to say that in
the state of New Hampshire we do not
racially profile people
we know that it happens
but this body should stand up and say
our law enforcement those who are tasked
to enforce the laws that we are passing
in this house
should not racially profile people
I am fortunate enough and blessed from
the almighty to not have been racially
profiled by police in this state
but I'm from Virginia
born there it happens it still happens
and because this hasn't happened to me
doesn't mean it isn't happening to
others in this state those in small
places
up north in college County
in big places big places like Manchester
it is happening we should codify this
support this bill OTP
thank you thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is ought to pass
on House Bill 596. this is going to be a
roll call vote
members take your seats
[Music]
motion before us is on a pass in House
Bill 596 this is going to be a roll call
vote chair recognized representative
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know racial profiling is
already illegal in the federal law
section 242 Title 18 makes it a crime
for a person acting under the color of
law to willfully deprive a person of a
right or privilege protected by the
Constitution or laws of the United
States and Mr Speaker if I know the main
argument put forward by the sponsor in
support of this bill
was we want to make a statement
and Mr Speaker if I know as a
consequence of this law police are
encouraged to implement quotas for
arrests based on race sexual orientation
or ethnicity
which is racist and sexist when I now
press
the red button
can recognize representative wheeler for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that we
should be judging people off the content
of their character and not the color of
their skin including those in law
enforcement and if I know that this
would be a statement based on law
affirming as the overseers of law
enforcement that they cannot racially
the green button on OTP thank you very
much Mr Speaker
the motion before us is ought to pass in
house bill 596. this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your poster press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote
186 148 185 voting a
I move reconsideration having voted on
the prevailing side and I ask the
a division has been requested this is a
the motion before us is reconsideration
on House Bill 596. this is going to be a
division vote chair recognized
representative Roy for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that racial
profiling is bad and Mr Speaker if I
also know that it's already illegal
federally
and if I know that by passing this law
we are basically saying to all the men
and women in law enforcement we don't
trust you and we think you are racially
profiling
would I not reconsider this vote
and
put it back to another vote so that we
could rescind that
without telling them that we don't trust
recognizes representative Weber for
parliamentary inquiry
Mr Speaker if I trust most of our Law
Enforcement Officers implicitly
knowing that they do very difficult work
on behalf of all of us every day
but if I also know that we owe every
single citizen in this state
the same safety in a traffic stop and
the same confidence in a traffic stop
that I experience as an old white woman
every time my toe gets a little heavy on
the accelerator
would I now press
the motion before us is reconsideration
of House Bill 596 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
foreign
members president had an opportunity to
185 vonier 187 149 motion for
for what reasons a member arise Mr
Speaker I would move that we print the
remarks on House Bill 596 in the
permanent Journal
huh
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 71 and act repealing
a Department of Education report on
chartered public school funding
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation to Bill ought to pass
it's in a while over Ford for the
committee
this is the one bill we don't have a
debate on are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye I suppose nay
the eyes have it and the committee
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 104 relative to
multi-stall bathrooms and locker rooms
and schools this comes to us without
recommendation
for what purpose does a member rise I
Rise to make a motion stage of motion I
would move a table for hb104
it is a proper motion the motion before
us is the table house bill 104. are you
ready for the question
a division has been requested who
Senator Weber requested a division
member
oh somebody behind you I'm sorry
um the division has been requested
chair recognizes representative Ladd for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you very much Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this is a
complex issue with safety concerns for
all
and if I also know that there are
potential building code issues
associated with this bill as well would
I now vote to table this bill by
pressing the green button
the motion before us is a table House
Bill 104 this a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if your opposal press the red button
voting stations are
football
[Music]
now voting stations are open for 30
seconds
foreign
[Music]
fall members president an opportunity to
345 voting a 28 voting May tabling
motion passes
also be in order
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 170 requiring the
teaching of course of handwriting and
multiplication tables
representative lab moves ought to pass
with Amendment the amendment is zero
three one six H printed in house record
15 pages 28-29 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say aye
as opposed no
the eyes the eyes have an amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is auto
the chair recognizes representative
cascadden
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker
fellow Representatives words are an
essential means of communication
yet how we put them down in writing has
been continuously shaped over time by
Technologies cultural and business needs
and education
and once a universal skill taught in the
school classroom handwriting fell out of
favor with the introduction of
Technologies to make designed to make
communication more efficient
by the mid-1990s emails became a major
form of communication followed by
texting in the early 2000s
schools began to place even greater
emphasis on computer literacy and
students are currently taking notes and
taking tests directly on laptops and
conducting research online
I don't imagine many here have
experience or technical knowledge in how
to teach cursive handwriting or
multiplication tables to the level of
proficiency
when was the last time you were in a
classroom and presented a lesson to 25
students
will I have a 40-plus year career as a
teacher a principal in a school
superintendent
I have taught cursive handwriting using
both the Palmer method and the slingolin
method
I have taught and supervised teachers
teaching multiplication tables based on
recommendation standards from the
National Council of teachers of
mathematics
state legislators have a history of
passing laws that become unfunded
mandates to all school districts
when did state representatives pass laws
on the tools processor requirements in
performing your root canal
or when did state representatives pass
laws on the devices process or
requirements for performing your hip
replacement
will HB 170 is no different it's up to
the professional Educators in their
local school districts to decide and
implement
since there already is an RSA on cursive
handwriting and multiplication tables
that addresses this topic the authority
and Duty lies with local education
leaders to support their schools for
implementation as they see fit
inappropriate
most if not all of you say you cherish
local control
decisions about the education of
children in a public school district is
made by those who are city or town
residents
who knows best what is vital and
necessary for instructional practices
than the residents in the teaching
Professionals in that District
who knows best the cultural physical and
emotional needs of their resident
students
local communities are responsible for
local schools and local communities
operate their local schools join me in
supporting our local school boards and
certified professional teachers by
voting no on otpa
thank you Mr Speaker
currently RSA
18911c
encourages instruction and cursive
handwriting and the memorization of
multiplication tables
HB 170 simply requires instruction in
these Topics by the end of fifth grade
the fact that students are not required
to memorize multiplication tables
anymore is alarming
according to the minutes from last
month's State Board of Education meeting
Jim Lewis superintendent of SAU 71
commented on the state's low math scores
and emphasize the importance of focusing
on basic math facts
I think it's no coincidence that test
scores
have declined as less and less
importance is given to the basics
memorizing the timetables may be tedious
and hard work
but it is also essential and comes with
a great reward
the ability to solve more complicated
mathematical problems quickly and more
effectively
cursive handwriting like multiplication
tables is another basic skill that all
children should be taught
21 states currently require instruction
in cursive that is a 50 percent increase
since 2016 as evidence in favor of its
benefits becomes more and more obvious
numerous research studies have all come
to the same conclusion
instruction incursive handwriting is
incredibly good for kids
it helps them develop hand-eye
coordination
strengthens their memory
and even improves the content of their
writing and it's especially beneficial
for dyslexic students
but you don't need to read academic
Journal articles to know the positive
effects that teaching cursive can have
on children recently I've spoken with a
few Educators experienced in teaching
cursive in the primary grades all of
them said the same thing
that kids felt empowered
by learning cursive writing they felt
like they had broken a code and that
accomplishment brought them great pride
even if some students don't go on to be
lifelong cursive readers the ability to
read cursive should be considered one of
the skills
that any literate person should have
because a lot of people still do write
in cursive including me including most
of you
the state has a constitutional
obligation to provide an adequate
education
RSA 189 already requires the teaching of
Health
physical education financial literacy
and a number of historical topics this
is currently the law under which
instruction in cursive handwriting and
multiplication tables is encouraged
all HB 170 seeks to do is to give these
two fundamental skills that are being
overlooked in many schools the attention
they deserve because an education
without them is not adequate
the motion before us is auto pass has
amended a division has been requested
motion before it's not a pass as amended
House Bill 170 this division vote chair
recognize representative hall for a
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker as a New Hampshire Public
School educator who taught cursive
writing multiplication tables and
computer literacy to many hundreds of
students during my 40-year teaching
career if I believe that given today's
increasing technological development
there is much debate on the value of
cursive writing instruction and the
memorization of multiplication tables in
today's curricular
and if I know that current law already
states that the school board of each
school district is encouraged to provide
instruction in cursive handwriting and
memorization of multiplication tables
and lastly Mr Speaker if I believe that
curriculum decisions should be made by
individual school districts giving local
control to Local School boards over
their students education
would I now push the red button thank
you Mr Speaker
chair recognize representative lad for
thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know the importance of teaching
cursive writing and student learning
multiplication facts in public schools
cannot be understated
and I if I also know research identifies
that cursive writing strengthens the
brain
strength and spelling and composition
better supports those with dyslexia
and should be required learning by the
end of the fifth grade in this state
if I also know there is overwhelming
evidence and general consensus that
knowing math facts by the end of the
fifth grade is essential to progressing
successfully in this subject area as
Massachusetts presently requires that
math B multiplication facts and tables
be memorized by fifth grade and their
scores are higher than ours what I then
require the learning of these basic
foundational skills by pressing the
green button thank you
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended in House Bill 170 to say
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your opposer
press the red button voting stations are
before
members president had an opportunity to
19948 174 voting a committee report is
adopted
majority committee on education to which
was referred House Bill 394 local act
relative to the organization of
Cooperative school boards having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it's in expedient to legislate it's in
Valerie McDonald for majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same be an unable to
agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation to build a lot of pass
representative Katie panternell for the
minority of the committee
thank you very much Mr Speaker those of
us on the education committee realize
there are issues when it comes to to
Cooperative school districts and we are
considering several initiatives on those
you'll probably see those next week
during uh during the house session but
House Bill 394 just totally misses the
mark
many of us serve towns that are members
of Cooperative school districts in fact
co-ops serve about one half of the 160
000 students who attend public schools
in New Hampshire
this bill takes management of these
Cooperative school boards out of the
hands of the voters
it requires board leadership and meeting
locations to rotate every year to change
every year from town to town for every
town in the co-op School District
first of all this can already happen now
if it was a good idea
without any need for legislation
Cooperative boards could just do this
but wow this sounds confusing
where's the next score board meeting
going to be held and who will be the
chair of the board
we're best to leave this management up
to the locals let's support the majority
a division has been requested members
foreign
spell 394. this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative Ladd for
if I know this bill provides the
opportunity for all districts within a
Cooperative School District to host and
even chair The Cooperative School
District School Board
and if I also know this bill is designed
to encourage more public input from
small communities that often seek
greater involvement in the governance of
a Cooperative School District in their
affairs
where I then support this small step
toward encouraging district-wide
involvement by pressing the red button
so an alternative motion can be brought
forward thank you very much Mr Speaker
do you recognize the representative luno
thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know locals already have the
ability to rotate the chair of the
Cooperative School District board
and if I know moving the location of
board meetings each year
would be confusing to most of the public
and not lead to Greater public
involvement
and if I know that half of us represent
constituents in Cooperative school
districts who wouldn't want a
heavy-handed law that dictates who
serves as board chair and where the
meetings are to be held than what I
press the green button and support the
majority report of Ito thank you
the motion before us is the majority
report of inexpension to legislature and
house bill 394. this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
well members president an opportunity to
226 voting a 146.49 committee report is
adopted
majority of committee on education to
which was referred House Bill 399 FN and
act allowing for a testing exemption for
graduation from high school consider the
same report the same with the following
resolution
that is inex community to legislate
representative Bell Mauer from the
majority of the committee
nor do you have a committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation of Bill ought to pass
representative Mike Belcher for the
minority of the committee
for what reason does a member rise
thank you Mr Speaker I moved to table
house bill 399.
that is a proper motion the motion
before is the table
House Bill 399. are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
as opposed May the eyes have it and the
pause
committee on education to which it was
referred House Bill 514 relative to
dissemination of obscene material by
schools and institution of Higher
Learning
comes to us without recommendation
for what reason does a memberize to make
a motion
Sage motion uh Mr Speaker I wish to lay
House Bill 514 on the table and I call
for a division vote
that is a proper motion the motion
Senator virgilis press the roll call is
that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
against
foreign
this is going to be a roll call vote
chair recognized representative luno for
thank you very much Mr Speaker if
complicated issue that needs serious
consideration but even with the
Amendments this bill is not ready for
prime time then would I press the green
button to support the tabling motion
thank you
do you recognize representative cordelli
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that we have heard
from constituents around the state about
concerns about some of the materials
they are seeing if I know that this bill
deserves a debate and discussion in
front of our constituents here today
the motion before us is to table house
bill 514. this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your oppose you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
do you want to vote in yay 175 voting a
committee on Election law to which was
deferred House Bill 590 also be in order
an act allowing the removal of political
advertisements containing a candidate's
name in which will appear to be the
candidates advertising on public
property by the candidate considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution result that is inexpediate to
legislate
representative Russell Muirhead for the
committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
Arizona
the eyes have it and the committee
committee on environment and agriculture
to which was referred House Bill 231 FN
prohibiting the removal the house will
the removal of Claws from cats this
comes to us without recommendation
representative jomana moves ought to
pass chair recognizes representative
Kelly
31 is a common sense bill that prohibits
decline of cats except medically
necessary
the bill specifically forbids removing
cat Clause to make keeping cats more
convenient for owners
declaw surgery is not a nail trim it's a
surgical amputation of the last joints
of a cat's toes the equivalent to
cutting off tip of your finger at the
first knuckle mutilation is not the
appropriate measure for unwanted
Behavior
except in rare instances declawing is
non-therapeutic meaning it has no
medical benefit the recovery is long and
excruciatingly painful for cats it
permanently changes how they walk
because their feet don't hit the ground
naturally
it also removes the cat's national
natural defense mechanisms even indoor
but similar to other bills that we all
care about there are no actual
statistics some say it doesn't happen
here
without this legislation Veterinary
clients seeking this procedure can
simply keep looking for a veterinarian
until they find one who will comply with
their demands it's cruel and unnecessary
and exceedingly painful so I ask you to
please pass the green button to pass
this thank you
thank you Mr Speaker and I'd like to
thank the the previous speaker my
honorable representative
I wasn't you wouldn't recognized
thank you Mr speaker
good morning house colleagues
I rise today to ask that you vote no to
OTP this bill hb231 which would ban the
declawing of cats in New Hampshire and
codify criminal penalties for
veterinarians who perform this procedure
this bill should be itl because this
procedure is rarely done in New
Hampshire there is no real need or
pressing need to ban this and no need to
codify harsh penalties
more importantly the vast majority of
veterinarians already discourage cat
Decline and instead work with cat owners
to use behavior modification techniques
to prevent the cat from scratching
family members or destroying property
when those techniques fail and the
veterinarian determines that decline is
the only remaining solution aside from
rehoming or euthanasia that should
remain a choice between the owner and
the veterinarian
I want to stress that declawing a cat is
a very last resort option
the American Veterinary Medical
Association respects of veterinarian's
right to use professional judgment when
deciding how to best protect their
individual patients Health and Welfare
and we should too
consider cases where a family member may
have developed an illness or autoimmune
disease which would put them at risk if
their cat scratches them consider too an
elderly person who has thin skin and is
taking blood thinners rather than
euthanize their beloved cat or rehoming
it as a last resort the cat can be
humanely and safely declawed and allowed
to live out its life in a loving home
it's not just a matter of convenience
sometimes it's a matter of health and
safety and if an owner has tried all
methods available to cease chronic
scratching and if declawing was made
illegal their options would be to
abandon the cat re-home it to an
unsuspecting home or Surrender it to a
shelter
cats like these do not suddenly stop
scratching behavior in a new home and
the new family would have the problem
cats that are brought to a shelter will
either live out its life there not a
life that I'd wish on any animal or the
shelter will euthanize the cat to make
room for more adoptable cat however if
the cat was able to be declawed he could
stay in his original loving home to live
out a great life and additionally if we
ban this procedure in New Hampshire then
cat owners who feel that they need to
have their cat declawed will simply take
it to an unfamiliar vet across state
lines to have the procedure done anyway
as for this being a cruel procedure it
can be argued that spaying and neutering
is also cruel
any surgical procedure that can be any
surgical procedure can be deemed cruel
or painful
only two states new New York and
Maryland statutorily ban this procedure
and they've also banned other
veterinarian medical procedures Banning
cat declawing in New Hampshire will set
a precedent for Banning other
veterinarian medical procedures which we
have already seen in my committee
furthermore
the criminal penalty in this bill is
really unenforceable who could prove
that a veterinarian did a declaw without
a medical reason New Hampshire
veterinarians should not have to worry
about being accused of Performing this
or any other procedure
and for all of these reasons I ask you
to please press the red button and vote
this bill in expedient to legislate so
the cat owners and their veterinarians
can together continue to be able to make
legitimate appropriate and informed
choices in New Hampshire and Mr Speaker
I request a division vote thank you
all right I'd like to apologize to the
speaker and especially to our honorable
chairwoman for jumping the gun there a
few minutes ago I'd like to point out
that first of all uh this is the penalty
uh in this case is actually a civil
penalty rather than a criminal penalty
that's an important point to make
addressing a couple of arguments that
were made in Committee in opposition to
this bill first of all regarding the
fact that we don't know how often this
procedure is carried out in the state
that it's true but it is also true that
we know that it is carried out in this
state two of the three cats that my
family has adopted from the Humane
Society in recent years were declawed
and they came from New Hampshire so we
know that it does happen the fact the
most reputable veterinarians will not
report or admit that they did it first
of all speaks to the cruelty of the
procedure but also makes it impossible
for us to have reliable statistics
there's also the argument this
intervenes in that relationship between
the client and the veterinarian
this law still makes it permissible to
have medical or therapeutic decline that
is a medical decision and that medical
decision certainly should be between the
client and the veterinarian in this law
keeps that in place
the Centers for Disease Control no
longer recommends declawing of cats for
people with immunodeficiency disorders
and we heard from a couple of Physicians
via letters to make that point
finally I would point out that since the
ability of the veterinarian to perform
this procedure for medical purposes at
their discretion remains in the bill all
that is left is the decline of cats for
the convenience of the owner and that is
simply unacceptable so I ask my
colleagues in the house to vote
a division has been requested members
the motion before us
is ought to pass on House Bill 231 this
is a division vote
the chair recognized representative
coulon
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that zero
evidence has been presented to suggest
that any New Hampshire veterinarian has
acted maliciously toward a single cat
and that this bill will criminalize our
state's veterinarians likely leading to
further prohibition of Veterinary
procedures and Mr Speaker if I know that
a vast majority of our state's
veterinarians choose to not declaw cats
voluntarily and those who do do so as a
last resort against extreme feline
behavioral scratching instead of
euthanasia and furthermore Mr Speaker if
I know that outlawing and banning
practices actually creates underground
markets for them would I please hit the
red button to ensure access to safe and
effective Veterinary practices in New
Hampshire thank you
chair recognized representative now for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that no one who testified in our
committee disagreed with the knowledge
that Kat decoy causes Lifeline life long
pain to cats with complications
including arthritis neuropathic pain
bone fragments left behind and changes
in behavior and I know that this
legislation would give veterinarians the
ability to point to state law and say no
to a procedure that most no longer want
to perform and if I further know that
Studies have shown no increase in
abandoned cats where the procedures
outlawed would I then press green for
ought to pass thank you
motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 231 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
foreign
had an opportunity to vote also attend
225 voting yay 147 voting a committed
committee on labor industrial and
rehabilitation services to which was
referred House Bill 58 FN prohibiting
payment of sub minimum wages this comes
to us without recommendation Senator
Sullivan moves ought to pass
0070h printed in house record 15 page
27. the question is on the amendment are
you ready for the question on the
[Applause]
the chair is in doubt the division has
been requested
members take your seats this is a
division vote
the motion before us is on the amendment
zero zero seven oh
this is a division vote for
clarification
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
four members president an opportunity to
184 voting a 182 voting a the amendment
is adopted we now on the bill
as amended
Geo recognize his representative
infantine
thank you Mr Speaker
you know we talk about tipped employees
people seem to like to focus on on
possibly waiters and waitresses and such
but you have to understand there's so
many different people that receive tips
from people the chambermaids uh for
people of
um drivers whether it be Lyft or Uber or
or limousine driver
a ski uh
um
ski instructors there are just so many
people that receive tips
but the bottom line is no matter what
you must receive the minimum wage
for every hour you work
okay so if you have a snow day like
yesterday two days ago where nobody was
there and you were you had you stayed on
site
even though the the tipped wage is 2.36
2.36 an hour you must stay there in your
St you must receive seven dollars 25
cents by your employer
so just so you understand that fact
now
I profess to know a lot of things in my
tenure in the labor committee about
Labor so things but I've never been a
tipped employee in my life so I don't
know what it's like so I started asking
some questions
and I've been fortunate enough to go out
to a few dinners in the last month or so
and it's amazing when you asked
someone about the system and the tip
wages what they say
it's it's funny because one of the
comments made in one of the blurbs here
is that while this may not generally be
a problem for a server who works at a
higher end establishment those who work
in bargain price restaurants struggle
under the current wage system
so I was at a diner
and I asked I told him who I was and why
I was asking
and they said well you don't understand
well
because people who eat breakfast in the
morning
they eat quick and they go I get more
tables I get more people that are come
and go they get in they get out and they
actually leave a better tip
because you know two people come in have
a quick breakfast it's
it's uh 15 16 they'll just leave a
twenty dollar bill
that actually this this waitress did
feel she did better
at one of those if you has described a
lower end
restaurant and then you know what she
told me she kind of set me back
he said I don't know what you people do
up there but will you stop fussing with
yes ma'am
um
because
every job is different
this individual works on Fridays and
Saturdays and Sunday mornings that's all
they want to work
they get some extra income for those
periods they work five or six hours
really hard and they like it and that's
what they do
versus another gentleman is this
full-time job at a nicer franchise
restaurant
and he gets fewer tables but higher tips
because people are drinking on Fridays
and Saturday nights so I learned this
whole thing about the different aspects
of different restaurants and different
tipping what I learned is two of the
three do not get paid the two dollars
and 36 Cents kind of difficult when you
start asking people personal questions
but they were very nice to me about it
one of them got paid five dollars an
hour the other one got the 725 an hour
plus the tips that is the decision that
those owners made
to get people to come into their
restaurant to work
because right now they have the option
they can go where they want because
everybody wants them
so it's this this thing that I say all
the time is some people get sick of
hearing me say but sometimes the
business owners know what they're doing
and they know what it's going to take to
get employees they know what's going to
like to keep employees
and I will forever remember
someone saying to me will you stop
messing with us we're fine so I would
ask us to stop messing with us and vote
against the ought to pass thank you very
much
thank you Mr chair Aaron go bra
speaker I did mean speaker
Erin go bra Ireland forever
Okay so
my first job with a W-2 was as a busboy
official title at a cheat cheese on
Dixie Highway in Louisville
it was eye-opening restaurant work
tipped wage jobs in general are easily
among the most
arduous jobs you can take and this state
being heavily
heavily active as a state for tourism
has a lot of jobs in this regard
and the good news is New Hampshire was
the first state to eliminate the
sub-minimum wage for workers with
disabilities
so this bill would bring it into parity
to have no workers with any note
especially tipped wage workers with
sub-minimum wage
in our sub minimum wage is actually
3.27 cents an hour here
contrary to what we just heard
and 11 other states have already
eliminated the sub minimum wage for
workers the the
woke States like Alaska Minnesota
Montana Nevada and I think Utah
and so we can compare those 11 states to
the rest of us and see how our
restaurants doing and we have that
information as a matter of fact on an
investor call
the owner or CEO of The Darden
Restaurant said well in California we
actually are doing much better we're
able to open more locations and our
workers are thriving and making more
and we know for sure that in one Fair
wage States
the tips in general are higher or the
same as States than States who don't
have one Fair wage so any
any thoughts of that to the contrary are
not true
um actually full service restaurants
in those 11 states there are more of
them than before and
um and here's the weirdest part about a
sub-minimum wage
doing research to find out why we even
have it
is very crazy we are literally the only
country on Earth that has a sub minimum
wage
and it's because of what our society
decided to do during emancipation
I think this is very relevant to the
debate to understand why we even have it
because it's senseless
and it's because when former slaves
entered the job market as workers by and
large the jobs that were in restaurants
in rail cars other tip jobs they it was
they did not receive any wage at all
other than the tips that they were able
to get at the behest of their customers
so so what more awful way to enter
emancipation than to be at the whim of
the customer
with all the great feelings in many
states in the South I'm sure that wasn't
very helpful at all
and so since emancipation in all that
time we've gone from zero wages to three
dollars and 27 cents an hour
and yes we are supposed to pay at least
a minimum wage the regular minimum wage
again confusing
um to all tipped wage workers
but this leaves our workers
are vulnerable to abuse and exploitation
to be that much at the whims of
um customers but more importantly there
have been multiple restaurants in New
Hampshire who have been found probably
not out of any necessarily Melissa's
malicious intent because the system's so
confusing multiple restaurants in recent
years have been
um
found liable
for wage theft and had to pay hundreds
of thousands of dollars in fines
including back wages to those workers
because so many folks
you know because it's so confusing don't
um
understand the right way to to pay their
workers while they're earning tips and
having
327 versus 7 25 an hour it's very
confusing
so
I could say many other things I'm going
to skip most of my other points and just
say a one Fair wage for our workers a
majority of whom are women
we have the highest amount of women who
earn one Fair which would be benefiting
from one Fair wage in New Hampshire the
highest per capita tipped wage workers
are female
so in passing a one Fair wage system it
would not just be less burdensome for
employers
it would be the right thing to do for
our workers and give that even playing
field to the West boys and all the other
tipped wage job workers that keep this
state
a Bastion of Tourism and many good
things thank you
so remember yield to questions
there's been a request for a roll call
by representative Santa natasto and is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
the motion before us is
ought to pass on House Bill 58.
this is going to be a roll call vote the
chair recognizes representative
infantine for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that I
made an error in 3.26 versus 320 3.27
cents and I apologize
and if I also know
that
businesses in New Hampshire have the
option to pay more for for the tipped
wage and do
and if I further know that I trust
businesses to do what they need to do to
take care of their employees
that I would vote against the OTP or the
auto pass and for for the motion
do you recognize Remington McKenzie for
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that everybody in
the state of New Hampshire needs to be
paid 7.25
and Mr Speaker if I know that the only
class of workers in the state of New
Hampshire
that is allowed to piggyback on their
employees
are those members of the restaurant
industry
and Mr Mr Speaker
if I know that the work is tips
are being used to credit
those restaurant owners unlike any other
business in the state of New Hampshire
and Mr Speaker if I know
that the fact that they can use the tips
of the workers
as an offset for their obligation under
the minimum wage law unlike any other
occupation in the state of New Hampshire
Mr Speaker if I know that this hurts
workers
that it affects their workers
compensation benefits that it affects
our unemployment benefits Mr Speaker
it's a parliamentary inquiring under
speech
okay I don't get up here that often but
I in my remarks it asks you to pass
press the green button thank you
the motion before us is on a pass on
House Bill 58 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button of your opposal press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote I also attend the
1676 voting yay 108.95 voting a the
moshevara pass fails
for what reason to memorize to make a
motion Mr Speaker stage of motion move
Senator Sweeney moves in expedient to
legislate and house bill 58.
a division has been requested members
foreign
students
before we go into the division vote
the correct vote for the previous
motion of ought to pass was 176 to 194.
a member
accidentally pushed the wrong button
for a person that was sitting beside him
so I just want to make sure that the
house will be in order we're making this
correction and that's what was taking
this is why you must be in your assigned
okay
the pending motion before us is
inexpedient to legislator in house bill
58. this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button of your opposal press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
well remember this president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
192 voting a 182 voting a the motion of
uh representative Hopson declared a
conflict of interest and did not
participate
debate on it so why don't we
start now for lunch and come back at one
o'clock
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker
um I I Rise to make an apology in my in
my haste to make a motion earlier uh in
an attempt at humor I had made some some
remarks and I called a distinguished
member uh out by by name my friend and
colleague from from Deerfield and we
really shouldn't be using each other's
names during speeches on the floor and
so for that I apologize for breaking
with decorum and I beg the Forgiveness
of the body thank you Mr Speaker
[Applause]
the committee on labor industrial and
World data services Georgetown they've
heard House Bill 125 relative to youth
employment during the school year
at night well this comes to us without
recommendation
representative Cahill rules ought to
pass an Opera's Amendment zero three two
eight H Clinton and house record 15 page
28. the question is on the amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
a roll call has been requested is that
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote on the amendment
this is the motion before us is
amendment zero three two eight h
this is a roll call vote and the roll
call is on the amendment
chair recognized representative seaworth
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the bill as it came was
originally introduced had a flaw in it
and if I know that that flaw was
identified by the lawyer from the
Department of Labor
and if my reading of this bill
and the amendment
would ban teens from working on Fridays
and Saturdays would I not vote no on
this amendment
chair recognize representative Cahill
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that the reading that my
esteemed colleague has is not correct
and that the amendment that we approved
merely changed the word uh
12 a.m Friday and 12 a.m Saturday to
midnight because as we were corrected 12
a.m Friday is the time that comes right
after 11 59 pm on Thursday
and the committee voting unanimously to
approve this amendment so there is no
there is no
Banning of anyone working on the weekend
what I now vote Yes implicitly green
button
the motion before us is the amendment
0328h this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor
you will press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
everything
representative Carol Brown
if all members president had an
183 to 183 the amendment fails
we're back to
ought to pass
chair recognizes Representatives
seaward
thank you Mr Speaker
in the years that our committee is poked
and prodded at this section of law I
have heard dozens of stories from
members of this chamber current and
former
stories about the virtues of working
your first job of a work experience
during High School
and I
experiences that would have been
curtailed if a bill such as this a bill
that would
restrict youth employment opportunities
would have been in effect in law
if I were to scale the experience of
this chamber up to the whole state I can
imagine that there are thousands of
unique stories from around the state
now some of these stories are probably
more impactful from others if
when you were 17 you had to knock off
work a couple hours early would that
really have changed your life maybe not
but I'm remembering one story that a
former member of this chamber told me
when he was 16 he was in a bad domestic
situation and he worked he worked a lot
he made some money he was able to buy
himself a car and that Independence
financial and otherwise allowed him to
get himself out of an abusive home
situation
now that's certainly an exceptional case
I'm not saying there are thousands of
stories just like his but each family
has their own unique situation
in committee
I heard it said a couple of times that
we can't make laws for the exception
that we need to make laws for the
majority
well I would challenge us where we can
just because a situation Falls outside
the norm doesn't mean we need to have
where families have their own special
circumstances let's let the parents not
legislatures do the parenting they can
work with the employers with the schools
with the kids themselves and make work
work
Mr Speaker if you would please join me
in pressing the red button let's not
legislate kids bedtimes
let's defeat this motion so that a
better motion can be made thank you do
ever
it's been habit we've heard it from a
number of people today who said the same
thing
I want everybody to think about Market
Basket
a lot of teenagers get their first job
there it's a great place to work
they offer scholarships to students who
want to go on to college
they are very accepting of anybody who
wants to work there
but they close at nine o'clock
the bill before you would would mandate
that the student working would have to
leave exactly as they closed the store
having had three children who have all
worked at Market Basket two of which
currently work at Market Basket but
they're older than this age crap group
they don't get to leave at nine o'clock
when they close down the cafe or they
close down the grocery section
or they're still pushing carts in
they're there till 9 15.
what we're going to do with this bill is
tell Market baskets and any other
employer that has a facility that closes
at 9 pm you need to bring somebody else
in do that last 15 minutes worth of work
I appreciate that the goal of the of
this bill is to make sure children have
a reasonable bedtime
but I'm not sure we could ever legislate
that and we definitely shouldn't be
telling employers how to re how to close
their business if they want to close at
9 pm please vote itl or please vote red
on autopath so we can bring up a
separate motion do you recognize
well I Want To Praise Market Basket
because the Department of Labor tells me
that they are one of the best at
adhering to the regulations
they don't have problems with them they
they do employ many teams my daughter
was one
they they do a wonderful job because
they pay attention they don't have the
violations because they pay attention to
it
um
further
the department also tells me that if
there's if there's so many punches out
15 minutes later that's not what they're
looking at they're looking at the abuse
they're looking at The Chronic situation
where someone is working a lot more
hours than they should be and I've seen
the violation reports and this is
something that does happen I'll also
note that the Department of Labor's
inspections are complaint driven they're
not look driving around looking for a
place to inspect
so back to my prepared remarks if I may
the the current law
has language
that says in any employer's
predetermined designated work week
during which school is in session for
five days
the
those who are 16 or 17 may not work more
than 35 hours
during that work week or okay so 35
hours is a lot it used to be 30 we gave
them 35 because we were trying to be
reasonable and business friendly on the
labor committee no problem
but that language about during the work
during the employer's predetermined Work
Week remains and if you look further
into legislation that allows an employer
to have a kid work 48 hours if there's
only four days of school that week I
don't think we want that
so another area that I that I tried to
correct in this in this bill is that our
law now says that
school people are in school
the law kicks in after Labor Day and we
know that we know that school starts the
last week of August so that's been a
disadvantage for our tourist industry
because the kids can't work as many
hours you know
until after you know that time
so that's an improvement for the for the
industry
and so what I've done here is I
clarified when school starts between the
date on which the school year begins and
the date school year ends because we
know some schools use a different date
that's local control
and so
other and of course they can work more
hours plenty of hours during the school
vacation weeks of which there are three
there's the there's one the February one
that we just shared with those students
then there's a December and there's an
April so there's three weeks plus summer
vacation that lots of students can get
lots of experience working without
without problem probably without
interfering with their academic work
which is why they're in school
so when you have somebody who's you know
a sophomore junior in high school
they're there to learn and they're there
to be to be at their best on their game
so to speak they shouldn't be tired from
working until 11 who knows 12 1 o'clock
in the morning driving home with that
they should be in bed they should have
got their homework done they should be
ready for the next day because that next
day
determines the rest of their life
it's not whether they had that car that
they wanted or the fancy outfit for the
prom those are nice memories
but what you do in school affects the
so
let me let me briefly say that the the
the minor issue that we tried to correct
was referring to midnight instead of 12
a.m I think the people on the other side
of the wall can fix that if they listen
to the labor department as I did but
there is nothing wrong with working
actually the bill says on the weekend
being the Friday night and the Saturday
night
they can work till midnight now some
people thought that was too much but I'm
trying to be good to their businesses
and to the kids who can do that
so I'd ask you to press the green button
and pass this bill
thank you Mr Speaker the motion before
us is on a pass on House Bill 125.
it's in a center natasto has requested a
roll side roll call and that is
sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
clear
motion before us is ought to pass in
house bill 125. it's a roll call vote
chair recognized representative seaworth
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the language that we're
seeking to change with this bill has
just gone into effect
at the end of last term and if I also
know that the committee heard no
specific issues with the law as it was
recently changed
and if finally Mr Speaker I know that it
is parents not legislatures that know
how to make the best decisions for their
16 and 17 year olds would I not press
the red button
chair recognized representative Cahill
that uh once upon a time I was 16 years
old
and I didn't make the greatest decisions
some of them I regret today
among them was not working quite as hard
as school as I should have
and if I know that Paris sometimes you
know as a parent myself
sometimes we don't we asked the kid
how's school today fine and we don't
know until the report card comes out
which as we know comes out after the
education was missed out the grades are
there or follow the poor performance or
the modest performance and if I know
it's hard to tell a kid you can't go to
work anymore when they really like to go
to work would I not help the business
Community with a more clear
statement on youth labor helped to help
the families get their kids to those job
experiences and get that education by
pressing the green button thank you Mr
Speaker
Emulsion before us is on a pass in house
bill 125. this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
175 voting yay 195 voting a the motion
fails
what reason is memorized to move in
the motion before us now is itl on House
Bill
125. are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
that was opposed nay
the committee on science technology and
entity to which was referred House Bill
208 FN establishing greenhouse gas
emission reduction goals for the state
establishing a climate action plan this
comes to us without recommendation
cinepratian moves ought to pass and has
1033h in your seat pockets
Doug Thomas
but
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I Rise
this afternoon to oppose the amendment
to house bill 208.
now on the surface it appears to be a
fairly innocuous Amendment it changes a
few dates from 2024 to 2026 1-2027 and
it adds a clause about funding for
but the amendment is essentially the
bill itself with just those few changes
that I mentioned
and the bill itself is a fundamentally
dangerous
proposition for the State of New
Hampshire
this bill could even though it looks
innocuous this good bill could actually
fundamentally change the way we live
it could allow government to dictate
what kind of car you drive
to dictate how you heat your home
to dictate where you can work
to dictate where you can go on vacation
or whether you could go on vacation
that's what a climate action plan
this legislation says the general court
declares that it shall be the energy
apology of this state
to achieve the greenhouse gas emission
goals identified in the climate action
plan
those goals are pretty draconian
and to achieve them would require
we better be careful how we proceed with
now I'll point out that the use of the
word goals
doesn't actually make this a mandate
but it would be an encouragement to
adopt policies that could significantly
I'd also point out that the 2009 climate
action plan contained 67 recommended
actions
one of which was to import
hydro and wind power from Canada
but the reality remains that putting a
policy like this in place the
representative will suspend for a minute
is is are you speaking to the amendment
or to the bill itself
Mr Speaker the amendment is the bill
so the bottom line here is simple
this amendment and is the bill itself
with a few small changes and it's a
fundamentally dangerous bill I urge you
to vote no on the amendment thank you Mr
Speaker there's a member yield of
questions
yes
remember yields thank you Mr Speaker and
thank you representative for taking my
question I'm looking at a section of the
amendment here and I'm trying to figure
out what this has to do with climate
action plans energy or the climate at
all where it says this plan must
consider opportunities to encourage
public and private investment towards
rural low moderate low-income low to
moderate income minority communities in
New Hampshire and provide for
opportunities for small businesses
schools affordable housing associations
and other community institutes to
participate and benefit from Statewide
efforts this sounds like some type of a
socialization plan and can you explain
thank you for the question
representative all this language is
designed to give government the power to
do virtually anything it wants in a
climate action plan
and that's one of the things that makes
it dangerous thank you
thank you Mr speaker thank you for those
interesting perspectives
uh this amendment makes a few
improvements and clarifications to the
language of the original Bill 208 in
response to the testimony that we heard
in committee and concerns that were
raised from my colleagues so mainly it
adjusts the deadline dates for the
reports and the first emissions
reduction goal to move them two years
into the future so which we heard was
necessary to make them more reasonably
achievable for Des
the amendment also adds a section as was
noted Section 5 that clarifies that any
costs the Des incurs that are associated
with Personnel or administrative support
to prepare the plan and Emissions
inventory should come from federal
grants which have recently been made
available specifically for this kind of
work or in the unlikely event that the
timeline for that isn't fast enough they
can use some of the funds that the state
receives from the regional greenhouse
gas initiative as a backup source
so please vote to adopt the amendment so
that we can vote on the best possible
version of this important bill and
ensure that the state has a climate plan
that will make us eligible to receive as
many federal dollars for federal or for
energy projects as is possible by
okay
okay the motion before us is the uh
a division has who requested the
division
division has been requested members take
the motion before us
is a floor Amendment 1033h this is a
the chair recognizes representative both
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this amendment is
fundamentally the bill before us
and if I know that this amendment and
this bill
is a massive expansion of government
influence over our lives
when I press the red button to say no to
chair recognizer of his integration for
if I know that a vote on the underlying
bill will follow the vote on the
amendment and if I know that the
amendment simply changes the dates and
clarifies the funding source for this
bill but I now press the green button
thank you
the motion before us is floor Amendment
1033h this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed or press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
fall members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend a state
[Music]
185 voting a 186 voting a the amendment
fails
we're back to
emotion of ought to pass
chair recognizes
thank you Mr Speaker
members
in my committee we're told often just
how far New Hampshire lags behind the
other states around us
that we should be more like the other
states around us
maybe that's why we're experiencing the
greatest influx of people coming in from
Most states in New Hampshire they like
New Hampshire we know how to we know how
to take care of our environment we have
clean air we have good mountain views we
have great beaches
this Committee Member the
agencies that we have here Des
Department of Environmental Services and
Department of energy they know how to
take care and guide us through the
environmental crisis that everyone is
looking at here and they've been doing a
great job
that's why we already have a climate
action plan it was in 2009
and we've done quite well with that
just a few days ago I learned that there
is federal money coming down that will
enable the Des to write an update
I asked the es do you need legislative
direction to write an update to your
climate action plan they said no
and since we've done such a great job
with the 2009 plan I have complete trust
that our
state employees will do a great job in
updating according to federal guidelines
what the next climate action plan will
be and using the money that is being
given to us by by the federal agency
so we don't we don't really need this
bill to write an update to a climate
action plan
what we need are good state employees
that know the common sense that New
Hampshire has to put in there what we
already know is doing a good job in
keeping our state so good that everyone
is coming here for both hiking
tourism and also to live
now the other part of this bill talks
about the New Hampshire energy
Department of energy
if this bill were to pass the department
of energy would would be would be tasked
with doing project planning
funding determinations and Rule making
this is not what the department of
energy is for it is it is uh basically
an economic regulator in our state and
it's done a great job so far
so if this bill were to pass that
portion would have to be funded the
department eventually would have to grow
with staff members costing us more money
on something that the department of uh
Des is already doing
so this bill isn't needed
what we need is common sense and Trust
in ours in our state employees to keep
up with the uh with the environmental
regulations that we already have to keep
New Hampshire going
we need that we also know that the the
requirements that this bill would do are
extreme
such as having zero emissions by the
year 2050 which we've seen reports
saying that's just not going to happen
plus affect our our economics in doing
so we are New Hampshire we don't want to
be like the rest of the states here
that's why we don't need HP 208 and
that's why we need to press the red
button
yeah I recognize representative
Christian
thank you Mr Speaker
this bill does too simple but critical
things
first it sets out a series of stepwise
goals for reducing greenhouse gas
emissions in the state in statute to 80
of 1990 levels or less by 2050.
then it charges the Department of
Environmental Services with creating and
maintaining plans to meet those goals
a sponsor sponsored this bill first and
foremost because the people of New
Hampshire want the state to have a
climate plan
with the exception of some date changes
this bill is actually essentially
identical to bills that were introduced
in the last two sessions in 2020 it
passed the house with a margin of 197 to
123 but unfortunately died of covet
death in the Senate last term it was
tabled along with many other bills from
this committee however the public
support for all three iterations of this
bill has been overwhelming with ten to
one margins signing in for the bill
versus against it we have a mandate from
our constituents to act on climate
a second reason that I sponsored this
bill is because I believe that we as
legislators have a responsibility to
protect our residents and our state
resources for future Generations
climate change is real and it is already
having negative impacts on our residents
businesses and the environment
warmer Winters are a killer for tourism
and revenues in the North country
hotter summers are bad for kids with
asthma and older people with COPD
warmer Waters and unpredictable weather
patterns are major challenges for our
fishermen farmers and maple sugar
producers
the science is clear that Global
weirding is happening at an
unprecedented rate due mostly to
greenhouse gas emissions primarily from
fossil fuels and that structural changes
will be required to slow it down
we have a responsibility to the Future
citizens of the state and the world to
do our part
with that said I recognize that climate
change alone may not be a persuasive
argument for everyone in this chamber
so let's talk about the money instead
there's substantial evidence growing
almost daily that Renewables and
low-carbon Technologies in general are
on learning curves or experience curves
and what this means is that unlike
fossil fuels which have cost essentially
the same price per kilowatt produced for
centuries
renewable Technologies are becoming
exponentially cheaper over time as
production scales and this includes
storage technology
they're far exceeding initial
expectations in terms of affordability
so this is actually amazing news because
it means that the sooner we make the
switch from oil and gas to solar and
wind and other new technologies the more
money we can save
excuse me I believe I have the right to
and this is not counting any costs of
climate change itself at all nothing
about the savings of preventing flooding
or wildfires or drought so just the cost
of the energy itself if you like
citations there's a really fabulous
paper published in the journal Jewel
last year that I can recommend that
shows these Trends clearly if you prefer
anecdotes I can tell you there are
already places many places in the
country where wind and solar are
regularly the least expensive sources of
electricity and again this Gap is all
but guaranteed to get wider over the
next couple years I really can't
emphasize this enough we literally
cannot afford not to switch to
Renewables as fast as we possibly can
for me it's also important to consider
that low carbon Tech presents an
opportunity to develop homegrown energy
from in-state companies so we keep more
energy dollars in the state
and because renewable projects including
energy storage projects can be cited
throughout the state they ultimately
help us build a more resilient
distributed grid
to be honest Granite Staters aren't
actually all sitting around waiting for
us on this we currently have many
Municipal and individual level efforts
in the state to produce renewable energy
but what we don't have is a guiding
binding plan at the state level to help
businesses understand where best to make
long-term Investments and to bridge the
gap between local projects and the
region level task of grid planning so
they can be more efficient avoid
planning missteps and delays and not get
left out of opportunities as our
neighboring states go forward
on the topic of opportunities let's talk
about the big one Federal investment
money to accelerate the transition from
fossil energy to Renewables is coming
and it's clearly going to be a game
changer for supporting Renewables
projects Nationwide
New Hampshire is not even eligible for
some of these dollars because we don't
have an appropriate state level climate
plan
and where otherwise at an enormous
competitive disadvantage among the other
states that feed into the New England
grid because yes Vermont Maine
Connecticut Rhode Island Massachusetts
all have ambitious and legally binding
greenhouse gas reduction goals they have
plans and state administrative support
in place to direct federal funds to
benefit their people and their
businesses and New Hampshire doesn't
so I'm happy to pay my fair share of
federal taxes as part of my duties as a
citizen of this great country but I also
want to make sure that my community is
going to receive our fair share of the
return on federal Investments
every other New England state has a real
plan with shovel ready green energy
projects they are aware all the dollars
for modernizing New England's energy
grid is going to go and they are where
the jobs created with these projects are
going to be so I don't know about you
but when I'm out knocking doors next
summer and fall I don't want my
constituents asking me why New Hampshire
is the only state in New England that
isn't benefiting from a green jobs boom
finally I do want to acknowledge yes my
colleague from Londonderry is correct
New Hampshire does technically have a
climate plan uh the first one was
created 14 years ago and it had
emissions reduction goals in lines with
the ones proposed here and in line with
what all the other states in New England
have now but it was essentially ignored
after the Lynch Administration ended so
if these goals had been put into statute
which is the difference with this bill
if we had actually followed the
recommendations set out in that plan
instead of undermining them if we had
stuck to the goal that was set then of
obtaining 25 of our energy from
Renewables by 2025. we would certainly
be less reliant on gas today and there's
every reason to believe that we would
have been more resilient to those
electricity price spikes that we saw
this year
and that final goal of an 80 reduction
by 2050 would be that much closer
so in Closing one thing that we've heard
over and over again this year when the
energy bills come up is that oh now just
isn't the time to invest in Energy
Efficiency Now isn't the time to invest
in Renewables
and you know what I actually I agree
with that the right time was 20 years
ago it was 14 years ago but we failed to
act at that right time so the next best
time to act the time that we have is now
let us not let another 15 or 20 years go
by let's not let our children and
grandchildren and constituents look back
at us and say the same thing that we're
saying about previous legislatures that
oh gosh this all could have been so much
easier if they had just acted back then
let's make energy transition a
bipartisan issue stop kicking this can
down the road and commit together to the
serious energy transition plan that New
Hampshire deserves thank you
representative has requested a roll call
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
absolutely
clear
the motion before us is on a pass on
House Bill 208 this is a roll call vote
chair recognized representative votes
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that 2009's New Hampshire
climate action plan ran to 74 pages and
recommended 67 steps the vast majority
of which were never implemented
including importation of Canadian hydro
if I also know that the Manhattan
Institute has identified at least 42
solid reasons that explain why Net Zero
by any date can never happen
which negates the need to plan for such
a contingency
and if I know that now is not the time
to expand government influence over our
lives
and finally if I know that creating such
plans is costly as well as ineffective
what I now press the red button to
relegate this bill to its rightful place
in The Chronicles of historical futility
thank you Mr Speaker
recognizes the Wendy Thomas
for join other New England states in
setting medium and long-term greenhouse
gas reduction plans and would require
the Department of Environmental Services
to prepare and maintain five-year plans
related to these targets and an annual
emissions inventory
and if I know climate change is
occurring and already having an impact
on New Hampshire businesses environment
and our state's health
and if the lack of a specific climate
plan to reduce greenhouse gas makes it
more difficult for municipalities and
businesses to make long-term investment
decisions and that we must have a State
climate plan in order to be eligible for
certain federal funding that is
dedicated to renewable energy project
project projects for the New England
grid
and finally if I know that setting and
pursuing ambitious greenhouse gas
reduction goals is both the right thing
to do from a climate an environmental
perspective
while also being fiscally and
economically prudent for the future of
this state
would I now do the right thing for New
Hampshire's energy and economic future
and press the green button for ought to
pass thank you
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 208 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your poster press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
representative
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
183 voting 887 voting a
motion of autopaths fails
for what reason does a member rise to
make a motion Mr Speaker stage of motion
the motion before us is inexpedient to
the motion before us is in expedient to
legislate and House Bill 208 this is a
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
representative
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
192 148 181 voting a the motion of index
speeding to legislate passes
Mr Speaker
for what reason to memorize I'd like to
move to place the remarks in the
well
this will be a division vote on printing
their remarks
if you want the remarks printed in the
permanent Journal
you'll press the green button if you do
not want the remarks printed under
permanent Journal you will press a red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
Mall members president had the
opportunity to vote also attend state of
214 voting a 159 voting a remarks will
be printed
for what reason does a member rise
a promotion Mr Speaker stage of motion
I'd like to move to reconsider House
Bill 208 and having voted on the
prevailing side I'd ask my colleagues to
motion has been made for reconsideration
on House Bill
208.
the division has been requested members
the motion before us is reconsideration
on House Bill 208 you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your opposer
press the red button voting stations are
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
186.48 187 voting a the motion for
also be in order
committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred House Bill
263 FN requiring notification to
Renewable Energy customer generators of
issues related to renewable energy
credits this comes without
recommendation representative McWilliams
moves ought to pass chair recognizes
thank you Mr Speaker
HB 263 brings us back to the land of Rex
not train wrecks not Tyrannosaurus Rex
but Renewable Energy Credit wrecks
remember from a previous from our
previous sessions utilities are required
to provide a certain amount of Renewable
Power
and the law says they can do it one of
three ways
building newer renewable production
but wait the vestment happened
so
utilities can own power production that
method is gone
so they can do it by buying wrecks from
suppliers who produce Renewable Power
or if they can't find enough of those
they can make alternative compliance
payments
now wrecks come from producers who fill
out
and get certificates these are generally
large large suppliers of Renewable Power
or they can be gathered up from the
multiple small producers who don't fill
out the certificate paperwork and this
is called wreck sweeping
it saves New Hampshire rate payers about
it's built into our statutes
proponents of this bill
have made the case that sweeping is
unconstitutional
it is way too loud in here the member
has a right to be heard if you need to
have a conversation
take it out to the annual
remember we may continue
so they're saying this is an
unconstitutional taking of an abandoned
property without proper notice
this is the same way that folks can
gather up your abandoned soda cans for
the nickel refund are constitutional
scoff laws
the bill requires the department of
energy to make an annual notice to all
small renewable energy suppliers
that must fill out the paperwork or
their utilities will sweep their Rex
values
that required mandate States among other
things
your energy May reduce overall renewable
generation unless your system is
certified
well I can assure you as an owner of an
uncertified solar tower
I generate the same amount of power if
my
solar energy is certified or uncertified
another statement that the doe is
requiring to make
the Federal Trade Commission may take
action against you if you Market your
home as running on renewable energy you
generate
with the fine of ten thousand dollars a
day
now the Federal Trade Commission
is to protect consumers and competition
by preventing anti-competitive deceptive
and unfair business practices
selling your home is not a business
whether you put a for sale sign on it
with a picture of a solar panel or not
on top of these claims the doe does not
have the resources to make these notices
or if it or if it asks the utilities to
do it
they will seek cost reimbursement from
the rate payer
the doe testified that they do not
support this bill
so let's let utilities do their job
sweep clean the wrecks and keep our
rates down
press the red button so that a better
motion can be made
Geo recognize it representative
McWilliams
renewable energy certificate sweeping
authorizes State seizure of renewable
energy property without the knowledge of
or any compensation to New Hampshire
businesses and residents Rec sweeping
enables both private multi-billion
dollar out-of-state corporations and
in-state utilities to use the renewable
energy that was generated by New
Hampshire residents to meet their own
statutory obligations
effectively short-circuiting the state's
solar goals in the renewable portfolio
standard
legal opinion obtained from multiple
members of the New Hampshire bar affirms
this state seizure constitutes an
unconstitutional taking of private
property in violation of the New
Hampshire Constitution as an attorney
myself I am very concerned that without
taking action this session the state is
allowing an unconstitutional practice to
stand effectively opening us up to a
lawsuit at the minimum we must provide
the constitutionally necessary due
process protection of quote adequate
notice to our constituents the New
Hampshire Supreme Court ruled in Royer
versus Department of Employment Security
in 1978 that the due process clause of
the State Constitution required notice
before terminating a person's employment
benefits this bill requires annual
written notification to all customer
generators affected by this statute and
this written notice is to show that
their energy production will be credited
to both the utilities and competitive
suppliers unless they fill out the
paperwork and obtain their own renewable
energy certificates this bill is about
notice
the New Hampshire Supreme Court has held
that the New Hampshire Constitution
guarantees quote notice of an impending
action that affords the affected party
and opportunity to protect their
interest end quote this is from the case
appeal of conquered steam in 1988. our
constituents renewable energy
certificates and their value are both
property interests that belong to the
individual and the government cannot
deprive its citizens of their property
rights without first providing notice
right this wrong provide notice prior to
rec sweeping pass this bill to help New
Hampshire residents and their businesses
green thank you
motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 263.
are you ready for the question a
division has been requested members take
foreign
ER members take your seats
the motion before us is ought to pass in
chair it's going to be a division vote
the chair recognizing representative
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that a renewable
energy certificate is like a grocery
store coupon
that must be redeemed to have any value
if I also know that sometimes people
don't need an incentive that a coupon
provides even if they know it's
available
finally if I know that reminding folks
via a letter of a coupon that they might
not want will take money out of the
pockets of every electricity customer
when I press the red button to stop this
nickeling and diming of red right pairs
thank you Mr Speaker
I recognized representative Kaplan for
Mr Speaker if I know that the practice
of claiming renewable energy credits
without notification by our utilities
and private out-of-state corporations
constitutes a taking of private property
of dubious legality
furthermore Mr Speaker if I know that
this house recently voted to Outlaw the
practice
of claiming renewable energy credits
without notification
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that
the fifteen thousand dollar cost of
sending out notifications to eligible
customer generators of renewable energy
pales in comparison to the cost of
defending this practice in court
when I now press green for ought to pass
thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 263. this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button every opposer press the red
button bony stations are open for 30
seconds
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote I also attend the
178 morning 186 voting a the motion
while to pass fails what reason a member
rise Mr Speaker I move in expedient to
legislate motion is to move
263 and expedient to legislate
are you ready for the question division
has been requested
much before his experience in hospital
263 and say division vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button of your opposal press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative raynham's
100 Mariners
can't push it
wall members president had a opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
under an 87 voting a 180 voting a motion
committee on science technology and
energy to which it was referred House
Bill 250 223 FN relative to net energy
metering limits for individual and
business customers this comes to us
without recommendation represent a
partial moves ought to pass share
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
the mo the noise in this chamber is
excessive the member has a right to
speak if you need to make a conversation
take it out into the ante room
remember may continue thank you Mr
Speaker in 1996 New Hampshire
deregulated the electricity Market
allowing utilities and even individual
customers to purchase the bulk of their
electricity on an open market
but there is an exception for utilities
they are forced to purchase any and all
excess electricity generated by their
customers at retail price rate they
don't get a choice here they must buy
this electricity even if there's a low
demand at the time of generation
by expanding net metering from one
megawatt to five megawatts this will
quintuple the amount of electricity
utilities are forced to buy all costs
related to this are passed down directly
to rate payers that's you and me
the other issue that comes up with net
metering expansion is reliability
when the utility buys electricity from
the wholesale Market those purchases
come with contractual obligation to
produce power this means the utility can
be sure that producers have an incentive
to deliver reliable power over the
length of the purchase agreement on the
other hand when utilities purchase net
metered electricity this comes with no
contractual obligation
when power is actually in demand a net
meter customer can choose not to sell
into the grid and conversely when
there's load demand the customer can
force the utility to buy
utilities cannot depend on net metered
electricity to reliably power the grid
to avoid blackouts and interruptions in
power the grid operators have to make
sure that there's always a backup of
reliable power ready to keep kick in to
keep things running
for every extra megawatt produced by
solar energy there has to be equal
capacity produced by other more reliable
methods
in conclusion net metering increases
costs for ratepayers and still requires
building out an equal amount of capacity
with other more reliable methods to
compensate for when the sun is not
shining
the department of energy does not
support this bill and I urge you to vote
Clean Energy Technologies have often
been accused of not being able to be
implemented without subsidies
however
no energy sector has ever been developed
without subsidies
refer to a great deal in our committee
about cost shifting
last year the long-awaited dunski report
on the New Hampshire value of
distributed energy resource concluded
that call shifting was less than one
percent
to quote Madeleine manal Chief Operating
Officer at Essex Hydro
now I can finally say there's evidence
there's no significant cost shifting
considering that we are looking at
160 percent Bill increases for energy
right now
going to say that one percent is not
significant
I'll be over there
well since we are impressed with big
numbers there's a few more
without a direct 20 billion dollars we
annually spend on fossil fuel subsidies
we'd all be paying roughly
12.75 cents per gallon what do you fill
the international monetary fund reports
that when tax rates and health and
environmental damages are not priced on
the cost of fossil fuel are included
this 20 billion figure
quickly Rises to 5.9 trillion or 11
million dollars every minute in fossil
fuel subsidies
to support a non-renewable fuel that
eventually price itself out of the
market is beyond foolhardy
we have better alternatives
one is to encourage homegrown energy
and raise a limit uh
metering limit from one megawatt to five
megawatt there's more seats were done
it will allow the installers of
renewable energy to take advantage of
economies of scale
a five megawatt system has to
significantly shorter payoff period as
mostly initial investment is in the
interface that connects the grid
and not in the generation
these generators not only create good
stability
but they also serve as load reducers
by way of explanation let me quote from
a recent New Hampshire bulletin article
producing energy near where it's used
saves money by lowering the cost of
moving electricity across major high
voltage transmission lines that come to
the state
a reduces how many energy utilities have
reduces how much energy utilities have
to buy from power plants
and also decreases how much utilities
have to pay plans to meet to be on call
to meet demand even when they are not
raising the limit will not result any
significant increase in short-term costs
but we'll surely have a long-term
benefit in cost sustainability and
stability
I looked at a final reason to raise the
net metering cap
we heard testimony from the IB
International Brotherhood of Electrical
Workers
that one of our larger breweries was
recently forced to lay off its workers
due to the high cost of energy
if they could have been reasonably
compensated for increasing their one
megawatt system to five megawatts they
could have avoid these layoffs and kept
more New Hampshire dollars in New
Hampshire
this is not to mention the need for more
Electrical Workers to carry out this
work and more jobs means a happy economy
we'll be voting soon next couple of
weeks on a bill to keep Burgess biomass
open and I'll confess I see this as a
badly needed jobs preservation bill
For the Love of those that toil to bring
us good ale let's treat them no less
fairly let's all take a step in the
comics of renewable economics of
renewable energy that's surely our
future
in conclusion
I'd like to recall a recent email from
an oil lobbyist I won't say the name but
they warned me of the Litany of demons
and snakes that would drain down upon us
if this legislation goes forward
I think my constituents are more
concerned about the demons that arrive
monthly in their utility bill than they
the house is past legislation the race
not merely in the past only to see it
die in the governor's desk
I urge this body to not only pass this
bill
but send a message by passing this bill
the motion before us is on a pass in
excuse me remember yield to questions
thank you Mr Speaker and uh thank you
representative for taking my question
if we agree on the laws of supply and
demand then is it true that the lower
the demand for other energy sources like
natural gas the lower the price thank
you
thank you representative Howard for that
question I think it goes without saying
that a free enterprise system is
dependent upon
prices working exactly as you say and I
think my constituents understand that as
I'd like to call for a division vote
the motion before us has ought to pass
in House Bill 523 a division has been
Senator Sweeney requests a roll call is
that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
player
the motion before is a lot of pass in
House Bill 523 this is going to be a
roll call vote chair recognizing
representative votes for parliamentary
inquiry
Mr Speaker if I know that expanding net
metering increases electricity costs is
demonstrated by our state's largest
utility collecting 20.4 million dollars
from ratepayers for net metering in 2022
alone
but if I know that my esteemed colleague
from Marlborough is correct
that cost shifting by net metering is
only one percent
as long as the limit is one megawatt and
that it goes up
if I also know that California recently
slashed its net metering subsidies by 75
percent
because climbing electricity costs were
harming that State's goal of increasing
finally if I know that only a commercial
developer can afford the capital costs
of any project bigger than one megawatt
and that subsidizing these businesses
for more than that amounts to corporate
welfare
would I now press the red button to
prevent seniors and single moms from
falling victim to corporate greed thank
you Mr Speaker the chair recognizes
representative
chair recognized who representative
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill
would increase the one megawatt net
metering cap for all renewable energy
projects to a more economical five
megawatts limit which would allow for a
quicker return on investment than our
New Hampshire businesses are asking for
and if I know that this bill would make
net metering invisible at the bulk power
level
and save transmission cost resulting in
directly benefiting rate payers
and finally if I know that this bill is
desired by our New Hampshire businesses
and would help them with their bottom
line and that this bill is a business
friendly moderate approach to net
metering that will help our New
Hampshire businesses stay competitive
would I now ensure our businesses are
heard and remain competitive by pressing
that elusive white whale and yet very
green button for ought to pass
thank you
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 523 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button of your opposal press a red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
foreign
members president an opportunity to vote
182 voting yay 189 voting nay the motion
of Auto pass fails
for what reason to remember rise Mr
representative Swinney moves in
expedient to legislate and house bill
523.
a division has been requested members
should still be in their seats
if the motion before us is
inexperiencing to legislate and House
Bill 523 if you're in favor you press
the green button if you opposed or press
a red button voting stations are open
wall members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
189 vote Eda 182 voting May motion of
any speeding to legislate
passes
what reason to memorize Mr Speaker
having voted on the prevailing side of
HP 523 I move reconsideration and urge
the motion before us is reconsideration
on House Bill 523 this will be a
division vote members should still be in
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button if only stations
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
178 voting a 193 voting Aid we consider
committee on science technology and
energy to which was deferred House Bill
524 refn relative to Regional greenhouse
gas initiative funds comes without
recommendation representative McGee
moves ought to pass share recognizes
thank you Mr Speaker I rise in strong
opposition to House Bill 524 this bill
will increase the yearly rate by 6.7
million dollars
a great pay of money and across to the
ratepayer and 70 million over 10 years
the most recent auction
price of 13.7 cents provided 43 million
dollars to the fund in our state to our
state and 39 million went back to the
rate payers
with the recent Spike at electricity
prices heating Transportation fuels now
is not the time for a tax increase to
rate pay us
I issued a boat
ideal on this bill
thank you Mr Speaker esteemed colleagues
nice to be back
um I very much respect my colleague from
Lancaster although I do have a
disagreement with him about this bill
um the regional greenhouse gas
initiative or Reggie as it is no the
member will suspend
[Music]
back away
[Applause]
[Music]
back away from them please let the
the house is in recess
boy
foreign
[Music]
order
thank you again Mr Speaker
esteemed colleagues
the regional greenhouse gas initiative
or Reggie a regional cap and trade
program
involves 11 states
and it helps fund investments in those
States in clean local energy Supply
greater efficiency and current
Technologies
states do this to help avoid the kind of
crushing price hikes we fell victim to
last year
though every state uses their regimoney
differently
only New Hampshire has chosen not to
invest their money to modernize the
state's energy economy
New Hampshire offered sorry New
Hampshire opted to offer electric bill
rebates so small that no one notices
them while our rates shot up over 150
percent
[Music]
last year New Hampshire received 43
million dollars under Reggie
by Statute we can only use the first
dollar of our allowances to fund energy
improvements last year the average was
about 13 as my colleague from Lancaster
mentioned currently in March the
allowance is 12.50 so around the same
but less than seven percent of that
money gets used for its intended purpose
and remember we've been spending the
Reggie money this way for years
giving 93 percent of our investment
Capital away
a couple of dollars per person per month
New Hampshire has received
262 million dollars over the life of the
program
and what do we have to show for it
if we keep doing what we've been doing
which is the absolute minimum
then we cannot claim that we're doing
all that we can to help people lower
their bills and deal with the high cost
of energy
it's really simple no investment no
return
it's not taking money from people which
is one way to spin it
it's putting some of that money where it
could actually do them some good
the bill asks us to increase that one
dollar
seven percent
to three dollars so tripling our money
to make investments
um and that would
uh turn into approximately 20 percent or
yeah seven percent times three is 21 but
just under 21 percent
but we would still be rebating eighty
percent of the funding onto the utility
bills of the customers so this is truly
a compromise as my caucus believes we
should be using eighty percent for
energy transition and
um like the other 10 states in Reggie
are doing
but having twenty percent of the annual
funding gives us at least a chance to
make the money work for our constituents
to do some things that are interesting
and to try and keep up in terms of
competitiveness we can give them supply
and demand side options
and truly bring down costs
we are not spendthrifts in New Hampshire
but we're not fools either
our lack of progress on local
sustainable energy has increased our
share of the regional transmission costs
on that Regional grid
we don't have to be the only state
member of Reggie who isn't seeing the
benefits of this wildly successful
program we can do something today
if you told your constituents that you
were going to do something to lower
energy bills then you can point to this
boat
as your follow through on that
representative San Antonio has requested
a roll call vote in that is sufficiently
seconded members take their seats this
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 524
this is going to be a roll call vote did
I recognize representative votes for
Mr Speaker if I know that the word
Investments is another term for taxes
and if I know that this bill reduces
Reggie ratepayer rebates
and will cost 70 million in the coming
decade
if I also know that efficiency increases
energy Demand by making products and
services more affordable
finally if I know that cost increases
this past year for home heating road
travel and lighting our homes have hit
near record levels
would I now press the red button to
allow beleaguered energy buyers to catch
a breather from Relentless price spikes
thank you Mr Speaker
do you reckon
for parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker
if I know that New Hampshire rate payers
are not benefiting from the rebate
program that was in place when they saw
their bills go up by hundreds of dollars
last year and if I know that an increase
in energy program funding from 7 to 20
percent would mean we could do more than
just Energy Efficiency to help people
lower their energy costs and finally if
I know that rebating 80 percent of the
regi funds to electric bills instead of
93 percent is a fiscally responsible
compromise that won't do all that Reggie
can do for New Hampshire but it will
help
then would I now press the green button
to give consumers the choices they
deserve to lower their costs thank you
the motion before us is ought to pass in
House Bill 524 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote I also attend the
181 voting a 186 voting 80 ought to pass
motion fails
for what reason does a member rise I
move in expedient to legislate Mr
Speaker the motion the motion before us
is in expedient to legislate on House
Bill 524 a division has been called
all members should still be in their
seats this will be a division vote the
motion is
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
foreign
[Music]
187 voting 880 voting nay the motion of
for what reason to memorize Mr Speaker
having voting on the prevailing side I
move reconsideration and ask the body to
every member should be in their seats
so the motion before us is
reconsideration
on 180 on House Bill 524.
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're a pulse you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote I also attend the
under an 80 voting a 187 87 voting a
speaker
for what reason to memorize Mr Speaker I
move that the remarks on House Bill 524
we need to take a vote on the remarks
being printed in the journal
everybody should be in their seats
division has been requested
this will be a division vote on their
remarks being printed in the permanent
Journal
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
well members president had an
opportunity to vote I also attend the
260 voting a 166 voting Navy the remarks
committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred House Bill
605 FN relative to solar generation
under renewable portfolio standards
comes without recommendations Senator
Reynolds moves ought to pass chair
thank you Mr Speaker
I come here opposed to hb605 for a
couple of separate reasons first is I
think everybody in this room and
everybody in New Hampshire has been
inundated with climate change global
warming information no one is ignorant
of the issue everybody is informed which
is good it's good to have an informed
public we also in New Hampshire have a
thing called Electric Choice everybody
gets to choose their electric supplier
they can choose based on cost or they
can choose based on the type of
electricity being produced they can get
all win for example and probably get all
solar for if they wanted to but this
bill says we don't want to give those
informed rate payers the ability to make
that decision we don't think they're
smart enough this bill says no no no we
can't trust the rate payers in New
Hampshire to make the right decision
when it comes to what type of
electricity to buy we the state are so
much smarter we must do that for them so
we are not going to allow them to do
that in fact we're going to increase the
amount of solar electricity they're
required to purchase up to 25 percent of
their total so that's the philosophical
reason the Practical reason is it's
never going to happen ISO New England
estimates the electric consumption in
New England and New Hampshire will
double by the year 2050. that's because
of addition of all these electric
vehicles and electric heating so given
that
is going to produce 25 percent of the
electricity consumed in New Hampshire
would take up thousands and thousands of
Acres of solar panels somewhere in the
vicinity of twenty thousand to thirty
thousand depending on what estimate you
want to use for how much acreage one
make wad of solar picks now remember the
big thing to remember about solar is
it's 13 and a half percent efficiency it
when it comes to capacity Factor so for
example something like a combined cycle
gas plant is maybe 90 capacity Factor
solar is 13 and a half percent so you
have to have many many more megawatts of
solar to produce the same as you would
from a combined cycle gas plant
now to put this in perspective thousands
and thousands of Acres like I said of
solar panels even if we got say a
quarter of those maybe four to five
thousand acres of behind the meter solar
which means backyard solar rooftop solar
Factory roof solar 5 000 Acres that's an
enormous amount of solar panels we'd
still be left with about fifteen
thousand acres that we'd have to come up
with where can we get that acreage in
New Hampshire only one place by mowing
down forests completely clear cutting
Forest to the ground to put it into
perspective
Pawtuckaway State Park is about five
thousand square up five thousand acres
so we would have to cover the patakaway
state park mow down every tree cover up
even the lakes and streams and that
would give us a third of what we need to
cover what this bill wants us to do so I
ask where are we going to come up with
these 15 000 Acres of forests that we're
going to mow down in New Hampshire and
by the way those forests are absorbing
greenhouse gases right now they wouldn't
be doing that when they were replaced
with solar panels so this idea came from
Fantasyland and it belongs there let's
leave it and fan let's leave Fantasyland
in Disney World where it belongs and
remember it does not yield
thank you Mr Speaker
good afternoon colleagues
HP 605 is a straight it's very
straightforward IT addresses only the
solar component of our renewable energy
portfolio standard
as you know the RPS is the policy that
requires our state's distribution
utilities to include in the electric
supply that they procure on our behalf
a gradually increasing amount of
renewable energy
hb605 would require modest increases in
the amount of solar energy that they
procure every year from now where we're
at a box about two percent to ultimately
achieve as my colleague stated 25
percent of our energy from solar by
2050.
so just to be clear that's 25 percent by
27 years from now
if you think that's too ambitious let me
remind you that New Hampshire among all
the states in New England has by far by
far the least ambitious renewable
portfolio standard I'm not allowed to
use props up here but if I were you'd
see graphs with lines representing every
other state going like this over time
and New Hampshire is like this
flatlined
despite this
I'll respectfully call it
conservative approach with regard to
renewable energy New Hampshire doesn't
have
lower utility rates than any other state
in New England that's because when it
comes to Energy prices
we're all in the same boat
New Hampshire utilities buy their
electricity from the regional power pool
and in 2023 more than 50 percent of
electricity in the region is produced by
power plants burning natural gas
at times of peak demand the power plants
burning oil come online and they
contribute extremely expensive
electricity to the supply so the rate
shock that all electricity customers in
New Hampshire which is have experienced
in the wake of world events and the past
year is a direct result of this over
dependence
on a resource that New Hampshire has
none of
we are not West Virginia Texas Wyoming
Oklahoma or even Pennsylvania
New Hampshire just like every other
state in New England has no natural gas
no fossil fuel of any kind
but unlike every new other New England
state New Hampshire remains stubbornly
resistant to policies that would
diversify our energy Supply
stubbornly dependent and dare I say
addicted to fossil fuels
because New Hampshire has no fossil
fuels because we're so dependent on
these Commodities whose prices are set
on the global market all New Hampshire
residents and businesses are price
takers
it's Global supply and demand world
events like Wars terrorist attacks
hurricanes and the Gulf of Mexico ships
getting stuck sideways in canals
that those things determine
the price ups and downs of fossil fuels
and electricity rates we have no control
our dependence on natural gas and oil
for the vast majority of heating and
nearly 60 percent of electricity
electric generation at peak times is an
enormous vulnerability for New Hampshire
this dependence and vulnerability to the
global fossil fuel Market are contrary
to the prize New Hampshire values of
self-reliance and Independence and
furthermore the six more than six
billion dollars we spend on fossil fuels
every year
yeah 500 million dollars a month
represents over two percent of our
state's GDP we send it out of state
to power our economy but it's lost
opportunity it's an export of our wealth
and resources it's our money literally
now in policy discussions like this
within our committee and without uh
discussions of friends on the other side
of the aisle I often hear references to
the free market how we shouldn't be
meddling in the free market with
policies like this we should let the
free market work in the belief that that
will bring us the lowest possible prices
well how do you like 22 cents per
kilowatt hour of electricity
brought to you by that free market for
fossil fuels
the electricity and natural price shock
that we all experienced last year and
which looks like it's going to continue
for quite a while
this is strongest possible evidence of
this vulnerability
in fact there's nothing free about the
electricity and gas utility markets in
our state or any state the
electricity and gas utility businesses
that we have today are
government-sanctioned monopolies created
over a century ago of necessity to bring
the massive Distribution Systems that we
have today into existence
they operate completely within the rules
according to the incentives and toward
the goals that we policy makers set for
them
so if we care about the prices that our
constituents see in this captive Market
if we care about rates and costs that
they face
we must use every tool that we have to
achieve increased portfolio diversity
that enhances our strength and
resilience in the face of global fossil
fuel markets diversity reduces risk
solar energy on the grid reduces demand
for fossil fuels
especially at peak times when the spot
market prices are highest
and thus it lowers costs lowers rates
for everyone
the costs of implementing the RPS that
you'll likely hear about in a in a pi
represent the investment in achieving
that portfolio diversity
as I said the global situation with
respect to natural gas prices is not
going to alleviate anytime soon
the global price is going to remain high
so we need to change what we're doing
here in New Hampshire
solar energy all renewable energy has
the singular virtue of having zero fuel
costs
yeah let me repeat that zero fuel costs
right it's just investment in capital
the RPS is an important policy signal
that says to Private Industry build more
solar the kind that has zero fuel costs
so it's policy makers responsibility our
constituents expect us to have the
foresight and the willingness to
understand the complicated energy
landscape
understand the capabilities and
advantages offered by new technology and
make policies that look over the horizon
to where we need to be 5 10 15 20 years
from now and we need to begin to turn
the massive ship that is our Energy
System
we must evolve the system to meet 21st
century imperatives and goals by taking
advantage of 21st century technology
send the right signals to this Market to
ensure it evolves to encourage and
support a more diverse renewable energy
Supply less and less exposed over time
to the whims of the global fossil fuel
Market
over which did I mention we have no
control
the RP in conclusion the RPS is a key
instrument an important Market signal to
achieve greater fuel diversity and
decrease exposure to those markets
that's why it's used by more than
two-thirds of states in the nation
New Hampshire should strengthen our
anemic RPS and HP 605 would do that on a
schedule and at percentages for new
solar that would still be well less than
every one of our fellow New England
states
so I urge you to vote ought to pass on
hb605 thank you it's a member of years
to questions
no member does not do request a division
vote
the motion before us has ought to pass
and House Bill 605 a division has been
the motion before us is ought to pass in
hospital
605 this is going to be a division vote
chair recognize representative votes for
speaker
if I know that subsidies are practically
the definition of free market
interference
and that this bill increases subsidies
for solar energy by 300 percent by 2024
at a cost of almost 12 million dollars
if I also know that this bill increases
rate payer costs by 400 million dollars
over the next decade
finally if I know that solar systems
provide usable energy in our Northern
State at only 13.5 percent of A System's
rated size
what I now press the red button to
prevent crippling future generations of
rate pairs with costs for a fabled
energy transition
thank you Mr Speaker
I recognize representative Corman for
Mr Speaker if I know that fossil fuels
such as natural gas are expensive are
subject to price spikes emit carbon and
cause money to leave the state when we
rely on them
and if I know that for every additional
megawatt of solar energy that we use
that is one less megawatt of energy from
fossil fuels that we need to buy and
burn
and if I know that solar energy has no
fuel cost produces no carbon or other
pollutants and can be made right here in
New Hampshire then Mr Speaker would I
press the green button and vote to
increase the amount of solar energy
produced in New Hampshire
question before us is the ought to pass
Motion in House Bill 605 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposer
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
all members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend to stay to the
vote
181 voting a 188 voting Aid you ought to
a reason to memorize to make a motion
stage of motion I move in expedient to
legislate
the motion before us is inexpeding to
legislate on House Bill 605
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
as opposed nay
the eyes have it and the inexped into
legislate is adopted
for what reason does a memberize having
voted on the prevailing side I moved
reconsideration of 605 and urged the
body to vote now
the motion before us is reconsideration
on House Bill 605
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
opposed no
I'm not sure who's doing that but that
ingredients
the committee on state and federal
relations and Veterans Affairs to which
was referred hcr4 an act urging Congress
to propose a constitutional amendment to
establish constitutional term limits for
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment a recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment Senator Thomas Manning for the
committee
amendment is
0470h printed in house record 15 page
45. are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Applause]
members only members take your seats so
be
the motion before us is the amendment
zero four seven o h the chair was in
doubt so this will be a division vote
if you're in favor you will press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open
president had an opportunity to vote
172 voting yay 196 voting May the
amendment fails
the question is now on ought to pass
on hcr4
chair recognizes representative
shurtleff
this speaker in
act 2 scene 2 of Shakespeare is Romeo
and Juliet
Juliet turns to Romeo and says what's in
a name
arose By Any Other Name Was smell a
sweet
and over the next five centuries that
could change to A Rose by Any Other Name
is still a rose
and there's enough changes in hcl4 to
let this bill stand alone
however some of the language is so
familiar to all of us and so close to
what we saw in hcir1 the Article 5
Constitutional Convention
that it could be that Rose
this bill does talk about term limits
and I'm sure my friend from Danville
will cover that
but let me just take a moment to read
the first paragraph of hcr4 and see if
it brings back memories to you like it
did to me
whereas Article 5 of The Constitution of
the United States of America requires a
convention be called by Congress of the
United States for the purpose proposing
an amendment to the Constitution upon
application of two-thirds of the
legislatures of the several States
in the next to the last paragraph of the
bill
that this application constitutes a
continuing application in accordance
with Article 5 of The Constitution of
the United States of America until the
legislature of at least two-thirds of
the several states have made application
on the same subject Mr Speaker as I said
last month this body voted
overwhelmingly to vote down the Article
Constitutional Convention by almost a 50
vote
majority
I would ask you to do the same again
today
I I know my good friend from Danville
will speak to the merits of what he
thinks is important about uh limitations
of terms
but the underlying issue this is an
article request an application as the
bill says for an article 5 convention
and I would ask you to please vote no
thank you Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker distinguished
colleagues hcr4 deserves your support an
article 5 convention is the people's way
to amend the U.S Constitution when a
runaway Congress will not do its
constitutional Duty historically
Congress has refused to heal itself
unless and until the people have made
their discontent plane by aggregating
sufficient support for amending the U.S
Constitution
this is most effectively done by the
aggregation of Article 5 petitions from
the several States
the federal government uses unfunded
mandates to effectively control State
legislatures local governments and we
the people
they insert themselves into Americans
most personal decisions and they have
destroyed a nation's fiscal security New
Hampshire has a balanced budget
amendment petition waiting to be acted
upon
let's be honest District of Columbia
politicians a more D.C politicians than
anything else the chances are extremely
high that they'll get it wrong if they
get it at all
here among the Grassroots is how elected
officials in both the states and the
federal government can get it right
let's think about it would members of
Congress really choose to risk losing
their seats by ending profligate
spending or cutting popular programs
when they could just instead raise taxes
or issue more unfunded mandates to the
states
the people aren't excited by a balanced
budget what they want is balanced power
they want Congress the president
and the courts to do what they were
given to do Under the Constitution and
they want state and local governments
left alone to perform other government
functions in response to the needs of
their own people
sometimes activists are portrayed as
extremists but in this case the
activists are the voters nothing could
be more reasonable than what American
people are seeking they are seeking a
return to the rule of law Liberty and
Order
Democrats Independents and Republicans
alike want the three Federal branches of
government to be limited to the powers
that were that are legitimate for them
to exercise under the Constitution if we
give them that we take care of a whole
host of ancillary problems including the
budget
we must not make the mistake of failing
to implement the needed constitutional
reforms simply because a different group
of politicians will be in charge in the
District of Columbia for the next few
years precious few politicians will
restrain their own power while they are
in office
even if the administration does choose
to exercise self-destrate self-restraint
for a few years we cannot afford to
leave our Liberty at the whims of
individuals by leaving the
Constitutional offenses that Safeguard
them in a state of indefinite disrepair
please vote ought to pass on hcr4 and Mr
Speaker I request a division vote thank
you Mr Speaker
the motion before us has ought to pass
on hcr4 a Division has been requested
[Music]
the motion before it says ought to pass
on hcr4
this is a division vote chair recognized
representative certler for parliamentary
inquiry
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know last month we defeated a similar
Bill to this uh with a strong vote of
itl
and Mr Speaker if I know the 250 240
public interest groups including the
John Birch Society the common cause the
NAACP AFL-CIO the Sierra Club and others
have come come out in strong opposition
to this legislation and lastly Mr
Speaker if I know that arose By Any
Other Name it still arose what I push
the red button to vote this bill down
thank you Mr Speaker
can I recognize representative mannion
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that Congress has proposed over 12
000 amendments to the Constitution since
1789 and yet the states have proposed
zero despite both having equal power to
do so and if I know that 82 percent of
Voters 87 Republican 83 Democrat support
term limits for congress showing rare
bipartisan agreement and if I know the
current system overwhelming
overwhelmingly protects incumbents with
only 20 percent of races being
competitive
and fundraising for their next race
becomes the primary focus of these
incumbents not serving their
constituents and finally if I know that
Congress has a current approval rating
of less than 30 percent and this is our
chance and our constitutional
responsibility to correct then I would
press the green button and support a
committee recommendation of OTP on hcr4
the motion before us is how to pass an
hcr4 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press a green button of
your opposer press the red button voting
[Music]
wall members president an opportunity to
145 148 and 200 224 voting nay
the motion of audit pass fails what
reason does the member rise
stage of motion and move that hcr4bitl
the motion before us is in between to
legislate in hcr4 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
[Applause]
the eyes have it in hcr4 is an expedient
everybody on transportation to which was
referred HB 54 FN actuella diff do
antique Tire inspections having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment a recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment it's an Alvin C for the
committee
the amendment is zero two seven two
eight printed in house record 15 page
27. the question is on the amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted the question before us now is
auto pass with Amendment are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
That was supposed nay you guys have it
committee on transportation to which was
referred HB 93 and act authorizing
municipalities to reduce speed limits
seasonally considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
result that is inexpected to legislate
so John Sellers for the committee
chair recognizes
for what reason does a member rise
for a motion Mr Speaker stage motion I
moved to lay House Bill 93 on the table
the motion is to lay House Bill 93 on
the table a division has been requested
the motion before us is the table house
bill 93. this is a division vote
the chair recognizes representative evil
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that New Hampshire supports
local control
and that a state can and does reduce its
speed limits seasonally from 25 to 25
miles an hour but towns aren't allowed
to
if I know that no one spoke against this
bill the municipal Association supports
it and Dot was fine with this change so
we should talk about this now
if I know pedestrian safety can't wait
another year
and if I know this body is filled with
newly elected current and former select
board members and town counselors who
probably think they know pretty darn
well what's best for their roads and
they might want to do what's right now
and not wait would I now press the red
button debate this issue and not table
this simple local control bipartisan
bill
do you recognize representative walls
for parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know this bill
came out of committee with a bipartisan
recommendation of itl because it's too
broad if I also know Mr Speaker one of
the co-sponsors asked me to try to get
it on the table because he thinks he can
make it a better Bill and pull in some
of the reins Mr Speaker if I know I said
sure would I now press the green button
thank you
the motion before us is inexpected
legislative and House Bill 93 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press a clean button of your oppose or
press the tabling motion I'm sorry
I'm getting tired
the motion before is is the table house
bill 93.
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you oppose you'll press the red button
foreign
Representatives magdalier Peterson and
Kaplan
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
205 voting a 162 voting a the tabling
motion passes
committee on transportation to which was
referred House Bill 198 FN modifying the
new Resident driver's license transfer
requirement this comes without
recommendation representative Gorski
moves ought to pass
thank you Mr speaker thank you
colleagues
so as we were debating this bill and
committee some things become had become
198 would require non-resident drivers
who establish residency in New Hampshire
to notify the New Hampshire Department
of Safety if they then choke cease to
become residents within 60 days or if
they're out of state driver's license
expires or is relinquished and then it
goes on with a bunch of other
requirements
which I'm not going to get into because
they are
overly broad very confusing and
difficult to keep track of what may or
may not happen I am worried about
unintended consequences the DMV
testified at the hearing for this bill
that they didn't know who would do the
Gathering of the information and who
would collect it and how it would be
disseminated
the fact is this bill is not ready for
prime time it would be it would be best
if
the sponsors took a stab at this at
another time so I would urge you to
vote no on the
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker existing
Law requires New Hampshire residents I'm
sorry requires new residents of New
Hampshire to transfer their out-of-state
driver's license to New Hampshire within
60 days
however we have evidence that it's not
being done back in 2017 the Secretary of
State and Commissioner of safety
compared the voter database from the
November 2016 election and the DMV
database and issued a joint report
stating that 6
540 individuals presented an
out-of-state driver's license while
using same-day registration to vote
roughly 10 months later when the records
were examined well beyond the 60-day
requirement of RSA 263 colon 35
only 15 and a half percent had sent
received a New Hampshire driver's
license
it is this dismal 84 and a half percent
unexplained non-compliance rate
that this bill seeks to address
this bill attempts to address this issue
by doing two things first it authorizes
sharing of information on voters who
registered with an out-of-state license
on an ongoing basis so the DMV can send
them reminder notices
and second it creates a requirement for
individuals who do not plan to transfer
their driver's license to explain why to
the DMV
the 2017 report identified a few
legitimate reasons why this could happen
such as moving back out of state or an
elderly person giving up their driving
privileges tracking these situations
will permit future reports to be more
accurate
this bill is also in part a follow-up to
the 2018 House Bill 1264 which clarified
the definitions of domicile and
residency in our laws effectively making
them the same thing
prior to this law one could in certain
circumstances be a qualified voter
without being subject to RSA 263 colon
35.
this is no longer the case
that law has twice been before the New
Hampshire Supreme Court
and both times the court has addressed
the interaction between it and RSA 263
colon 35's requirement to get an
in-state driver's license and the court
has indicated that there are no
constitutional issues
thank you Mr Speaker and I urge everyone
to press the green button
remember yield to a question
remember does not yield
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 198. this is a division vote
emotionally Forest is not a pass in
House Bill 198 this is a division vote
which I recognized room representative
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that the DMV has no
way of knowing who was moved into or out
of the state
and if I know there is no mechanism for
enforcing HB 198 or managing the program
and if I know that there are no
penalties for failing to comply with
this law
what I now press the red button to
defeat the ought to pass motion
so that another motion may be made
chair recognized Roof Center Walsh for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know the data
from past election shows that we have a
dismal 15 compliance rate with our
requirement for new residents to get an
in-state driver's license
also like to see the DMV send courteous
helpful and information informative
reminder notices to voters who presented
an out-of-state driver's license for
same-day registrations and are not in
compliance
if I also would like to see the DMV
track valid excuses so the reports can
be more accurate finally Mr Speaker if I
know this topic has been addressed twice
by the New Hampshire Supreme Court in
recent years and found to be
constitutional would I now press the
green button thank you the motion before
us is ought to pass in house bill 198.
that's a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
your opposed or press the red button
foreign
[Music]
members president had an opportunity to
under an 87 voting yay 182.49 the motion
I'd like to make a motion
State commotion I've been voting on the
prevailing side of
198 I move reconsideration and encourage
the body to vote no
motion before us is reconsideration on
a division has been requested
the motion before us is the
reconsideration motion of house on House
Bill 198. this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed or press the
red button voting stations are open for
foreign
[Music]
members president had an opportunity to
181 148 188 148 the reconsideration
motion fails majority committee on
transportation to which was referred
House Bill 222 FN AC to require the use
of seat belts during the operation of
Motor Vehicles having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolve that as inexpedient
to legislate instead of Ted Gorski for
the majority of the committee
minority having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass from Senator Daniel
Bay you for the minority of the
committee
thank you Mr Speaker colleagues I'm here
to ask for your support for hb222
I knew this bill was going to be hard to
get through
I understand that being the only state
in the country without a mandatory seat
belt law for adults is one of the badges
of Freedom we wear in the Live Free or
Die state
expected strong opposition
I live in New Hampshire for a reason
same I appreciate the freedom I
appreciate what we have
I don't take this bill lightly
I would never sponsor a co-sponsor a
bill that didn't that I didn't think
provided value above and beyond the cost
I can't think of anything more valuable
than saving lives
there is no question that seatbelt to
the single best and least expensive way
to prevent Serious injury or death and
Yates
nationally
now that's over
90.4 percent of Motor Vehicle occupants
buckle up yet more than 50 percent of
the deaths occur within that 9.6 percent
who are unrestrained
in New Hampshire only 75 percent
of vehicle occupants buckle up and
accordingly two-thirds of the deaths
that occur in New Hampshire are to
restrained motor vehicle occupants are
50 percent less likely to die in a crash
and sixty percent less likely to sustain
serious or potentially life-altering
injuries
but none of these statistics matter if
we believe that failing to wear a seat
belt is only a risk to the unrestrained
person
but we know that's not the case anything
that is not secured in a vehicle will
become a dangerous projectile in a crash
including a human body
a person weighing 150 pounds will strike
another occupant with the force of 4 500
pounds
in a collision of 30 miles per hour
imagine how much damage you could do to
a child
or other loved one if you simply fell on
them now imagine falling on them at 30
miles per hour or more
seat belts prevent secondary crashes by
ensuring the driver can continue to
control the vehicle the driver who
sustains a serious leg injury which is
very common to under strange drivers as
they slide under the dash cannot apply
the brake to prevent the vehicle from
rolling into traffic going to a busy
intersection
a driver that is displaced from the
passenger seat cannot steer a vehicle
out of the traffic lane
and most disturbingly understand
unrestrained occupants are ejected from
a vehicle almost a third of the time
often becoming just another piece of
road debris that other drivers must
avoid
not wearing a seat belt increases the
risk of severe injury putting stress on
the availability
on the ability of First Responders and
medical professionals to provide
adequate care to everyone those who are
the sickest of the or the most seriously
injured receive care first imagine being
injured because you weren't wearing a
seat belt and knowing that someone died
because the med flight helicopter was
diverted to fly you to the trauma center
without the heart attack victim who
arrived at the ER at the same time
didn't make it because the medical team
was preoccupied with getting you
stabilized
New Hampshire is about freedom but it's
also about personal responsibility
so many states and countries around the
world have seatbelt laws because they
work
It is Well understood that getting
people to buckle up is a three-legged
stool of Education engineering and
enforcement no matter what other safety
features a car has they cannot match a
Simplicity and efficacy of seat belts
it has been proven that marketing and
education alone cannot persuade people
to wear seat belts no matter how
convincing the statistics or gruesome
the injuries
this law is Taylor Made for New
Hampshire
just to be clear it is a secondary law
meaning you cannot be pulled over simply
for not wearing a seatbelt
the fine is extremely low
and there's a Litany of Common Sense
exceptions to the law HP 222 is simply
the Third Leg of the stool it sends a
message that wearing a seat belt is
still a choice but helps emphasize of
buckling up is simply common sense
Mr Speaker request a
thank you Mr Speaker and colleagues I'm
going to take a slightly different tact
on this
I want you to think about an 18 year old
hitchhiking cross country
picked up
fairly quickly given a ride down the
road and that car crashes and rolls over
neither the driver nor the passenger
were wearing a seat belt
the driver
did not survive
the crash
the passenger survived the crash
in this course of time that passenger
got Addicted by his doctor
to drug painkillers because of the the
back the broken back that he was gotten
that person
by the way was my brother
and he went on to have a lifetime of
pain
and disappointment and difficulties
until at the age of 50 he passed away
leaving a a wife and two teenage
children
I bring this to your attention because
it's high time that we recognize that
the myth that only the person not
wearing the seat belt is the person who
gets hurt or killed or whatever and it's
a myth
family suffer other people suffer and we
have an obligation to try and alleviate
that if we can
I would also ask my colleagues
colleagues who I've been in the fire
service like I have or was for 28 years
colleagues who are police officers
those of us who have been
responding to crashes and have seen some
pretty difficult things
and I would urge you to look inside
yourself and think about what is the
best thing for the people of New
Hampshire never mind the politics of it
what is the best thing for those people
based on your experiences and I would
urge you to vote
against the itl so another motion could
be introduced
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues I played the lottery today
and I won the esteemed gift of being the
last speaker of the day
the coveted speaker of the day
I stand up to opposition today of HB 222
Mr Speaker I came here today and I I
buckled up my seat belt matter of fact I
buckle up my seatbelt every day when I
get in my car I do this because I choose
to
this bill is my esteemed colleague from
Amherst mentioned is a secondary offense
according to this bill meaning a law
enforcement official cannot stop you and
pull you over if you're not wearing a
seat belt
but let's not kid ourselves
this is the first step in making
mandatory seat belts for adults
we do have mandatory seat belts for
children 18 years in Unger
this bill does infringe on article 2B of
our constitution in which individuals
let's make let's not make
hurry up and buckle up your seatbelt an
Olympic event whenever a person is
pulled over from law enforcement
we are to live for you die state
let's have our citizens make that
decision to whether we're a seat belt I
ask you to press the green button to
support the majority's opinion thank you
Mr Speaker
representative Senator natasto has
requested a roll call and it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
the motion before us is inexp the
majority committee report of inexpion to
legislator and house bill 222. this is a
roll call vote
chair recognized representative Rumbo
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that total motor
vehicle crashes have continued to climb
in New Hampshire year to year and the
average inpatient costs for unbelted
crash victims is 55 percent higher than
belted crash victims
and if I know that New Hampshire is the
only state in the country without an
adult safety belt law has the lowest
seat belt use rate if nearly 10 to 20
percent lower than every other state
and the highest unbelted fatality rate
in the country
and if I know that this bill would be
enforceable only as a secondary offense
meaning that a driver may not be stopped
by police for failure to wear a seat
belt alone
and if I know that passing HB 222fn
would increase safety belt usage
decrease injuries lower costs and save
lives would I now vote no and push the
red button so that another motion may be
made thank you
chair recognize representative Corker
Mr Speaker
no that New Hampshire has a has a lower
overall or traffic fatality rate per
mile driven than a majority of the
mandatory seat belt law states and I
know that if wearing your seat belt is
as smart and safe thing to do but I also
know that this is New Hampshire and we
are the Live Free or Die State and we
don't need the government making that
decision for us would I now hit the
green button and I tell this bill
thank you the motion before us is the
majority commit a report of any
expedient to legislature in House Bill
222 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if your opposed you'll press the red
button boning stations are open for 30
seconds
foreign
members president had the opportunity to
vote
206 phoning yay 162 voting a committee
chair recognizes the member
from Auburn representative Osborne for a
third reading motion
he resolved that the house now adjourned
from the early session that the business
of the late session be in order at the
present time that the reading of bills
be by title only and resolutions by
caption only and it all bills were
ordered the third reading be read a
third time by this resolution and then
all titles of bills be the same as
adopted and then be passed at the
present time and when the house adjourns
today it be to meet Wednesday March 22nd
2023 at 9 00 A.M
thank you
question is on the third reading motion
we still have announcements in the
unanimous to consent so
third are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye those opposed
chair recognizes representative Weiler
attention my fellow Master Masons You
Know Who You Are
in about an hour about 5 30 on Ironworks
Road we'll be meeting at the Masonic
temple there to have some food and have
Joe recognizes representative magliore
speaker we have a hugely important date
that we want to announce and want to
make sure that you put in your calendars
please note Monday June 26th why it's
not the date of the first in the nation
primary but something equally important
we're Reviving The legislative Golf
Classic
and the proceeds for the Golf Classic
yes uh June 26 Loudon Loudoun Country
Club of golf scramble 36 teams shotguns
start at 8 A.M
shotgun all right shotgun is a golf term
we to shoot a gun to start the uh the
golf we keep we can ring a bell though
okay so we're going to have 36 we're
aiming for 36 teams of four we can start
registration next week and we'll
hopefully sell out in advance but if not
we'll have same-day registration
I just hope we don't have busloads of
Massachusetts golfers coming up here
I'm sure that's not going to be a
problem and a presumably Loudoun has
electric carts okay
[Music]
representative I I have some bad news
and some good news the bad news is
Louden has uh gas powered golf carts but
the good news is that uh you can write a
10 checkout to honest Mike moffett's
and I will plant a tree for everyone who
has to use a
uh they go out too soon
too soon
it's funny but a little too soon you can
uh and real quick couple other things uh
we're looking to have an executive
Council uh Team we have four we happen
to have four uh Republican executive
counselors so uh sorry elections have
consequences yeah well then uh if
elections have consequences why don't we
have a blue team of our federal
delegation that would be a foursome
but along those lines I'm sure you're
going to get support maybe from some out
of state folks maybe Nikki Haley will be
here and Mike Pence and I don't know you
could have a whole crew from Florida
come up huh
is a uh there's a couple guys from
Florida that may be around but uh I have
a feeling that by June Gavin Newsom
well what we know for sure is that there
will be great food raffle prizes special
guests shirt silent auction and
competitions for the longest drive and
nearest pin and a hole in one where you
can win a Prius that's true
they talked to representative infantine
he's going to help us with that you can
win it doesn't have to be a Prius it
could be a pickup truck so we'll work on
that
Mulligans will be for sale for those who
don't know Mulligan is a do-over yeah
and if you don't know what Mulligans are
it's extra shots you can buy they have
to pay money for that and sometimes to
make money The Mulligans cost money but
I'm sure the Biden Administration can
uh so how about Mike if we uh if we say
we're gonna hit from the white tees for
Equity fairness and inclusion is that
good well there's red teas and blue teas
as golfers know uh I would be fine with
the dumb sitting from the blue tees but
if you want Equity then the white tees
for all I guess can can work obviously
we're having fun with this folks but
it's a very serious uh and enjoyable
event where the proceeds go to a great
cause so please pencil in the
legislative Golf Classic for Monday June
26th at Loudoun Country Club even if you
don't golf trust me there'll be a great
social afterwards you won't want to miss
the 19th hole in the events afterwards
with special guests and let me or
representative Moffett know if you want
to reserve a spot Mr speaker thank you
so much
famous speaker
[Applause]
uh Republicans we will caucus in the
chamber as soon as we are done here
today don't worry it won't take a whole
lot longer than the last announcement
do you recognize representative Rose
thank you Mr Speaker just a very brief
unanimous consent
to say a hearty welcome back to the
ranking member of the science technology
and energy committee
our esteemed colleague from Hollis has
been out for six weeks recovering from a
serious health issue and we're thrilled
to have her back welcome back welcome
thank you
[Music]
I recognize
thank you Mr Speaker
there's this meme online that takes many
different forms but the basic setup is
you see a picture from years back
in a picture from now and the title says
something along the lines of feel old
yet
and today I would like to share with the
house some phrases that will likely have
the same effect on you as they do on me
whenever I hear them
weapons of mass destruction
axis of Evil
operation Iraqi freedom
next week March 19th and 20th
marks the 20th anniversary of the
beginning of the war in Iraq
I remember clearly being seven years old
and watching President Bush on
television give Saddam Hussein in Uday
and kude Hussein 48 hours to leave Iraq
for the youngest Millennials and oldest
gen's ears the global war on terror
shaped in many of our formative years
whether it was being picked up from
school early on the morning of September
11th
we're hearing your president on
television every day there was an evil
doer somewhere with wmd who needed to be
dealt with
having grown up in that time I know full
well that that conflict is a divisive
topic and I want to avoid that for today
because the fact of the matter is
4491 American Service members lost their
lives in Iraq as well as hundreds of
thousands of Iraqis
and I would ask for something a little
unorthodox and ask you all to stand with
me as I read into the record of the
names of the 23 New Hampshire service
members who lost their lives in Iraq
Edmund Lowe staff sergeant United States
Army from Salem
David stelmat specialist Army National
Guard from Littleton
Nathan Hardy chief petty officer United
States Navy from Durham
Justin McDaniel private first class
United States Army from Andover
Jonathan gaspob Captain United States
Army East Hampstead
Justin Rollins specialist United States
Army from Newport
Toby Olson specialist United States Army
from Manchester
Matthew Stanley specialist United States
Army from Wolfeboro Falls
Ryan mccon Lance corporal United States
Marine Corps from Manchester
Nicholas arvantes Corporal United States
Marine or United States Army from Salem
Matthew Schneider specialist United
States Army from Gorham
Daniel Garnett Sergeant United States
Army from Pelham
Douglas dicenzo Captain United States
Army from Plymouth
Nicholas cornellier private first class
United States Army from Gilmanton
Robert Macio
Lance corporal United States Marine
Corps from Salem
George roll private first class United
States Army from Manchester
Timothy Gibson Corporal United States
Marine Corps from Merrimack
Adam Brooks Lance corporal United States
Marine Corps from Manchester
Alan Burgess specialist the United
States Army from landath
Jeremy rajneer specialist United States
Army from Littleton
Richard Ferguson Master Sergeant United
States Army from Conway
Randy Rosenberg Sergeant United States
Army from Berlin
Robert Rooney Sergeant First Class
National Guard from Nashua I ask that
you keep these folks in your thoughts
and prayers on this solemn occasion and
foreign
to move the remarks of the member in the
without objection remarks will be in the
camp in the permanent Journal chair
thank you Mr Speaker
two years to the day eight people died
across three spas in Atlanta
of the eight kill six for Asian women
violence against Asians and Asian
Americans had both preceded and followed
that day but it marked an important time
in history
because it appeared that the country was
finally acknowledging would have been so
clear to Asian Americans from Washington
State to Washington D.C
here in New Hampshire our small
constellation of Asian communities
rallied in support of the victims and
their families days later
not because we make up a large portion
of the state's population
but because we don't
we knew that so many would rather suffer
in silence than share their pain
a difficult truth is that there are no
impediments to how far hate can reach no
barriers to the feeling of loss no walls
to Shield us from grief
but the same can be said about love
compassion and empathy
just for that reason that I stand before
you today to commemorate those lives
lost in a city a thousand miles from
Concord
I don't know if any remarks are made to
this legislative body back in 2021 but
I'm hoping that now is my colleagues he
will join me in a moment of silence for
always remember rise Mr Speaker I move
that the remarks be placed in the
permanent journal what other objection
foreign
because this is the side most deserving
and in need of my apology
three weeks ago went through a series of
motions that appeared that we were about
to reverse the fate of a bill and the
acting speaker unexpectedly called to
recess ostensibly in order to affect the
outcome amongst much consternation in
the chamber I expressed my displeasure
by loudly exclaiming a profanity
that was disrespectful
and not rising to the standard I would
hope for this body
despite my personal fondness of colorful
language I do believe in Civility and
therefore I genuinely apologize for my
language and lack of Civility on that
day
this has been an interesting learning
moment for me because I had only just
the previous week testified in two
separate committees on this very topic
the issue of Civility and good
governance
and if you would humor me I would like
to invite you into that learning moment
with me
in both of these committees I spoke
about the importance of small D
Democratic consensus to good governance
the idea that we all agree to the same
set of rules and so we are okay even
with outcomes that we don't like because
we believe that those rules are fair we
bemoan how divided and polarized and
uncivil we have become
but that polarization is not actually
because we disagree on things like taxes
and abortion and guns it's because we
don't trust each other to not cheat
because as long as people believe that
the process is fair people tend to
accept outcomes
but it turns out that when we stop
engaging in good faith civility becomes
forfeit
the problem is that we do not trust each
other in this room
and worse we have every reason to not
trust each other
more than anything in my six plus years
in this chamber I have been apoplectic
at the games we play all both sides
bills die not because they are bad bills
but because of what party or what
personality sponsors them and we use
insincere arguments to do so
we spend our time strategizing on how to
make the other party look bad rather
than working to find good language to
solve problems we're more concerned on
how to ingratiate ourselves with chairs
or party leaders and angling for
leadership positions or how to score
points on our opponents whenever someone
experiences a personal failure in their
lives
but we look the other way when one of
our own team engages in unethical
Behavior
we come up with titles to make us feel
Superior and then we fight over who gets
those titles and use those titles as
leverage over others we twist rules
designed to uphold the will of the
majority while protecting the rights of
minority in order to subvert those very
Concepts we find ways to suppress
testimony or suppress reports or
schedule hearings or execs strategically
or structure activity on session days
all to win
to win no matter what no matter the
principles of fairness we have to
sacrifice on the altar of winning
this is why the people hate their
government
and the thing is I'm not telling any of
you what you don't already know or even
what the entire State doesn't know the
emperor wears no clothes
civility is good
but civility alone is meaningless
it is not enough to curtsy to each other
while we burn down principles of good
governance
civility must be backed with good faith
engagement so I can and I truly do
sincerely apologize for my lack of
Civility
and I hope one day we will all be sorry
whenever we see these games played
in the rules of good governance
perverted because I know the people of
[Applause]
[Music]
what reason does it remember rise I
moved at the remarks of the previous
speaker we put in the permanent Journal
without objection
thank you Mr Speaker
the New Hampshire house is a place where
all of our members and all of our
constituents are to be respected with
regards to their religious beliefs
this
thus scheduling crossover day on the
first day of a major Jewish holiday is
inappropriate and fundamentally wrong
the date needs to be changed
understanding that there are deadlines
that we need to meet I am still
respectfully asking the speaker in the
house to make that change so that the
house can demonstrate its resolve
to serve all of our diverse communities
[Applause]
representative Osborne moved at the
house standing recess for the purpose of
introduction of bills enrolled build
amendments and Road build reports and
messages are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
I suppose nay the eyes have it the
motion is adopted the house is in recess